dark souls is one of the best series of
all time and has one of the most complex
yet remarkable narratives i've ever had
the pleasure of uncovering it's filled
with so many ideas themes and values
that breathe life into the series and
its various interpretations allow people
to add in their own details ultimately
making their playthroughs a unique
experience so today i want to take some
time to talk about the trilogy i want to
not only retell the game's main stories
but also critique them along the way i'm
going to examine why specific parts of
the game are so well crafted and how its
world design and bosses shape the story
around them
so with that out of the way thank you
for watching and i hope you enjoy
dark souls 1 is a fantastic game it's
got a wonderful story that would set in
motion numerous events that would occur
throughout the trilogy but just within
the bounds of its own game dark souls 1
has some incredibly deep and rich lore
filled with some of the greatest
backstories this series has to offer and
today i want to discuss why so without
further ado
let's get started so the opening
cinematic of dark souls 1 starts at the
gray world one that is filled with giant
trees and dragons and while the world
stayed like that for a while one day
fire was born as for how this fire came
to be well it's never explained this is
one of the many things we just have to
accept the world of dark souls is
fantasy and many things just can't be
explained it's never mentioned how the
first flame was created as it just
happened but because the first flame was
born disparity came with it life and
death heat and cold and light and dark
this description is literal since the
first flame was created the people of
the world felt its warmth and understood
what heat was when they walked away from
the flame they realized its heat didn't
reach them which created the feeling of
cold the discovery of fire during the
stone age is to this day the greatest
discovery known to man and in dark souls
this is no different given how unique
something like this in the world of dark
souls was those who discovered it were
obviously attracted to its power four
notable people would discover lord souls
next to these flames and be given
immense power these people were neato
izalith gwyn and the pygmy from the
intro we can infer that there was a
civilization of people that existed
during the age of ancients izalith had
daughters that were with her when she
found her lord's soul and gwyn had his
nights with him implying that people did
exist during the time of the age of
ancients but weren't of much value to
the world given how powerful the dragons
were eventually nito izalith and gwyn
would band together and use their power
to overthrow the dragons gwyn used his
lightning izalith used her flames and
nito used his death and disease they
also received help from a seath the
scalise a dragon who betrayed his own
kind now that the new lords were on top
of the food chain the age of ancients
was no more and the age of fire had
begun this period would last thousands
of years until we get to today currently
the fire is fading and it needs to be
rekindled in order to keep it lit but
doing this is not as simple as it sounds
you may have noticed i forgot to talk
about the pygmy well the pygmy had a
unique soul called the dark soul using
his soul he created something called
humanity he would then share this
humanity with his people these dark soul
imbued people became known as humans the
pygmy is essentially our ancestor gwyn
feared this power though and created the
dark sign which inadvertently caused the
undead curse this isn't explained much
in dark souls 1 but it is by far the
most important plot in the whole series
and while i just wanted to talk about
this game for the whole video this needs
to be explained or else the rest of the
video going forward will make no sense
the undead curse the dark sign and the
fading of the fire are all linked the
dark soul gets more powerful the closer
the fire is to fading thus meaning
humans should get more powerful over
time but gwen screwed humanity twice by
rekindling the flame thus removing our
chance at power but also by branding
humans with the dark sign think of this
as a literal wall of fire that prevents
the dark soul within men from getting
too powerful the dark side only
activates when the flame is fading
because that is when the dark soul
within men starts to grow stronger this
dark sign also prevents humans from
dying but it also causes them to go
undead these fleshy creatures were once
undead humans but they have crossed the
barrier of no return even though humans
are able to revive after death
eventually this will cause them to lose
their humanity lose their minds and lose
their purpose causing them to go hollow
these creatures are hollows beings who
don't even remember who they are where
they are or what they're even doing gwen
likes being on top and he fears the day
that he will lose his power so he'll do
anything he can to prevent that from
happening he did this by branding
humanity with the dark side but by also
rekindling the flame which is known as
the first sin see the world is like a
set of operations things are born but
eventually they'll die but then more
things will be born only to die soon
after that's just the way the world
works but gwynn broke the laws of the
world by rekindling the first flame it
was meant to be extinguished but due to
gwyn wanting to hold on to what he held
dear he couldn't dare see it go he
sacrificed himself by using himself as
kindling for the first flame since he
had one of the four original lord souls
that came from the first flame it was
deemed sufficient enough to be used as
fuel unless the gauge of fire continued
but as we know it is fading once more
the undead curse is back humans are
turning hollow and the world is in chaos
doesn't this sound like a fantastic
story
that's because it is this intro and even
the game display a sense of desperation
within our characters how far are people
willing to go to get what they want or
keep what they have and while each of
their desires is different it always
comes out the same dark souls 1 is just
the start but the actions of its
characters will continue to echo
throughout the entire trilogy and we're
just getting started after the opening
cinematic we get to see the state of the
world as it is today or at least the
state of this prison we're an undead
that is sitting in their cell awaiting
the end of the world but one day we're
given the key to our cell and are able
to leave this person is oscar and he
speaks of a prophecy there is an old
saying in my family
thou who art undead are chosen
and thine exodus from the undead asylum
maketh pilgrimage to the land of ancient
lords when thou wringeth the bell of
awakening
the fate of the undead thou shalt know
this prophecy also happens to be the
main objective of the game but it's only
the first part the rest will have to
discover later the intro of dark souls 1
sets up a new world by showcasing
multiple important events in the world's
history and also gives us enough
information to understand the basic
premise of the game while also purposely
withholding some of that information to
give us a reason to seek out said
information one thing we need to
consider though is our character's
motivations why even bother making the
trip to lordran the land of lords well
what else is there to do it's the end of
the world and you were just given the
keys to your cell allowing you to
explore the world to your heart's
content even if you're convinced that
life is doomed in the world as we know
it will disappear for good why not make
the most out of it have some fun kill
some hollows it's a whole lot better
than rotting in a cell with our
objective laid out to us thanks to oscar
we can now set out to lordran and ring
the bells technically the first area
you're meant to go is the undead burg
but one wrong step and you can make it
to new londo out of all the souls games
dark souls 1 will provide the best blind
playthrough as due to its connected
world players will go in different
directions which in turn will create
different experiences new londo is
actually a late game area since the
enemies here are quite strong and the
boss at the end of the level is quite
tough but you may stumble upon this area
by accident within 5 minutes of arriving
this is due in part to dark souls 1's
level design which may have the best
level design in the whole franchise it's
been coined as a metroidvania a genre
that started with the game's metroid and
castlevania these games have non-linear
progression as many areas can be
accessed right away but others can't
causing the player to go around the map
looking for the key then running back to
that same location such as this door
that leads to havel which can only be
found in the dark root basin past the
boss the door is found pretty early on
in your playthrough but the key is found
much later plus you'll also have to
remember where that key goes you'll be
doing lots of running in this game the
highlight of one of my play sessions was
going from blighttown to andre because i
forgot to ascend my weapon before a boss
fight meaning i had to take a three
minute walk up to him then a three
minute walk back down in future titles
this would be remedied by fast travel
but dark souls 1 doesn't have fast
travel initially and even when you do
gain the power of fast travel via the
lord vessel it's not the typical fast
travel we're familiar with as we're only
allowed to travel to specific bonfires
these decisions further immerse the
player into the world as it's all one
connected level and since they're all
connected that means you can see certain
levels from different places such as
blighttown which is visible from
firelink shrine so not only was the
level design of each area taken into
account but also how the levels
connected to one another and how this
connection would affect other areas
regardless of where you end up though
whether that be nullando or undead berg
the very first enemies you'll come to
see are these hollow men like the ones
back in the asylum all the undead we see
here are humans who have lost their
humanity causing them to go hollow and
now since we are human we should go
hollow too however it's a bit more meta
than that hollowing is a bit hard to
define as everyone could go hollow for
different reasons but the two main ideas
seem to stem from constant death or a
loss of purpose given that our character
is set on ringing the bells he never
goes hollow despite being undead as he
still has a purpose should the player
quit and uninstall the game they would
lose their purpose so permanently
quitting the game is sort of like
hollowing in a sense i don't think
everything needs to be explained with
lore so this is more than likely just a
gameplay mechanic but that's how i've
interpreted hollowing on our way to the
bells of awakening we'll come across
various different locations but sadly
there isn't a whole lot of backstory
involved in their creation locations
like undead burg are just undead
settlements and the valley of drakes is
just a valley filled with drakes the
only exceptions though are ash lake and
blighttown blighttown is next to a
location called the depths and at the
end of the depths is the gaping dragon
and while an interesting boss what's
more important is the arena we can see
water coming from the depths and going
into the sewer system which leads to
blighttown according to various keys in
the game we can piece together that
those who previously lived in the undead
bird but were banished from the
settlement were sent to blighttown as
punishment this is reinforced by the
giant door that separates the sewer
system from the outside world but this
water from the sewer is poisonous well
in blighttown there's a spell called
poison mist and according to its
description it seems that enki this
egg-bearing individual may have caused
this as he was the creator of the poison
miss spell it's not fully confirmed that
he did this but it's clear that
blighttown isn't in the greatest state
and it's due to the circumstances
surrounding blighttown that the
townsfolk seem to have built above the
water in hopes of getting away from it
this is a common theme in these games of
things being built on top of one another
as we see blighttown above the swamp the
depths of a blighttown and the undead
burg above all that the idea of pushing
things down and leaving them to fester
is also a common theme within this game
but not everything is in such a sad
state as at the lowest point of lordran
we see ash lake a seemingly infinite
land filled with archeries that are
surrounded by an equally infinite body
of water for the purposes of asha lake
this seems to be where the dragons used
to live for at least one part of it as
it's eerily similar to the environment
in the intro which we do know was the
land of the everlasting dragons we can
even find one of the few remaining
dragons down here in ash lake he's a
part of the dragon covenant in game and
from various descriptions it seems like
many people worship the dragons and
tried to ascend to their level it's
unclear though if that worked once the
player feels confident in their fighting
abilities they can approach the bosses
defending the bells of awakening these
being the bell gargoyles and chaos witch
quailag after bringing both bells we'll
see that sen's fortress a place that was
originally blocked with a large gate is
now open but if we travel back to
firelink shrine we'll find a primordial
serpent named frampt he claims to be a
close friend of gwynns and also claims
to know our fate
very well
then i am pleased to share
chosen undead
your fate
is to succeed the great lord gwyn
so that you may link the fire
cast away the dark
and undo the curse of the undead
to this end
you must visit anor londo
and acquire the lord vessel just like
before this second part of the prophecy
also happens to be our newest objective
but frampt is quite a complex character
if certain conditions are met within the
game we can also be granted an audience
with koth he however tells us a
different story your ancestor claimed
the dark souls
and waited for fire to subside
and soon
the flames did fade
and only dark remained
thus began the age of men
the age of dark
so it wasn't just the fact that the fire
was fading that caused gwen to rekindle
it the flame actually went out
furthermore despite being the same
species both frampt and coth have
different views on the world frant wants
to keep the age of fire going but koth
wants to usher in an age of darkness the
question is who do we trust
well that's up to you as these are the
two endings of the game extinguish the
flame or rekindle it the choice is yours
what is important to note though is
their motivations why are they doing
this why are they against each other
well we still don't know and it's been a
widely debated topic that hasn't been
given a proper answer yet regardless i
don't think you should trust any of them
frampt claims that the undead curse will
be cured if we link the flame but this
isn't correct as we'll see in dark souls
2 and 3 the curse is still present
frampt and koth are like politicians
they say what needs to be said but never
elaborate by technicality the undead
curse will be cured when we link the
flame as we know the dark side only
appears when fire fades and if it's not
fading then the curse of the dark sign
is gone which means the curse goes with
it but it will eventually come back
things are meant to run their course so
over time the fire will fade again and
the curse will come back just not in our
character's lifetime frampt whether
intentional or not is leading the player
to believe that the curse will disappear
permanently when indeed it only just
disappears for a few thousand years but
koth is also lying as he isn't fully
explaining what this age of darkness
entails and as we'll see koth isn't
exactly the nicest person in the soul's
universe i've always seen these two as
immortal beings ones that are ageless
and due to this when the time comes they
like to move the pieces a bit and see
what happens koth and frampt are
basically playing a long game of chess
but without the stakes regardless of who
wins they both continue to live one just
managed to convince the chosen undead
more so why not cause a bit of chaos a
lie or two here wouldn't hurt anybody as
it's just extra pieces on the board to
them to this day we still don't know
what they really want from us and
whether their goals they conveyed to us
were actually genuine my interpretation
of these could be wildly incorrect but
that's the beauty of these games they
allow you to shape your own story and
create your own adventure and in my
story i don't trust these two regardless
of who you believe the one thing they
agree on is that we need the lord vessel
thus we need to get to anor londo to get
there we'll need to pass through sen's
fortress a place filled with deadly
traps and is easily the most infuriating
area in the whole game the fortress is
also used as a sort of trial as this
leads us to anor londo but many people
have tried and failed to get there this
is of course due to the numerous traps
throughout the fortress and the iron
golem at the top although he was
surprisingly the easiest part of the
fortress once the golem is defeated we
are then grabbed by these demons and
taken to anor londo
[Music]
it's hard to forget your first time in
anor londo nothing up until this point
has been more extravagant and beautiful
looking than this place and that's what
makes it so memorable in a world devoid
of beauty and color there's this
incredible place that just exists but
it's on the other side of the wall but
something is off it feels empty like we
showed up late to a party and in a more
metaphorical and literal sense we have
this place is gorgeous but if you'll
excuse the pun it's also quite hollow
lots of your time in anor londo is spent
walking but if you manage to make it
past these giants and exploit the ai of
these silver knights then you'll make it
to the climactic fight of ornstein and
smo ons is undoubtedly my favorite fight
in dark souls 1. the balance of these
two is unmatched as orenstein is a quick
nimble fighter that can go halfway
across the arena just to hit you but his
damage is nowhere near as staggering as
the force that is smo where as ornstein
instills fear from his speed smo's fear
comes from his power ornstein at the
beginning of the fight is more or less a
pushover he does deal decent damage but
it's not enough to warrant a healing
item but no amount of damage resistance
especially this early on could protect
you from smoe's hammer and one hit from
this hammer can make orenstein seem a
lot more threatening their power grows
from the other's presence as the more
ornstein chips at your health the closer
you are to being within one shot range
of smoke and if smoke hits you once well
there's nothing that can compare to that
level of stress they feed off each other
in such a balanced way in fact they
actually feed on each other as whoever
falls first becomes the power source for
the other their health also goes back to
full so it's never about dwindling them
down over time it's committing to one
and sticking with it the problem is
knowing when to strike and how given how
well they complement each other it might
seem like there's never an opening and
that's what makes them such a difficult
fight all that's required though from
the player is patience it's arguably one
of the best fights in the game and even
the series as a whole and i can finally
see why while ons may seem like the
climactic finish to the level hold your
load as behind them is the real climax
the princess of sunlight guinevere
feel free to interpret climax however
you want she is the one who gives us the
lord vessel we need to progress through
the game but as i said earlier it feels
like we arrived late to a party well i
wasn't lying once the post nut clarity
settles in if we attack gwynevere the
world of anor londo shows its true
colors and reveals that it's just as
depressing as everything else in lordran
and the one responsible for this
illusion is dark sun gwyndolin gwyndolin
is an interesting case to me as he was
the last born child of gwyn who was a
male but was raised as a female this was
due to his strong affinity with moon
magic i'm not sure what the connection
is but maybe it's some sort of cultural
thing where the moon is seen as a sort
of feminine symbol which would actually
explain a lot regarding a future game
and two of its characters gwyndolin also
created the illusion of anor londo to
seemingly entice the chosen undead to
continue their duty remember gwyndolin
only appears when we kill gwenevere's
illusion meaning that this is actually
gwyndolin speaking to us through his
sister he also shares the same
viewpoints as frampt which is
interesting as he's basically telling us
to kill his father and continue the age
of fire gwyndolin seems to want to hold
on to the power his family has and keep
things running smoothly which is why he
wants the age of fire to continue so
that his family and their powers can
stay and the reason why he created the
illusion of anor londo was also to
desperately hold on to the past
ha i guess it runs in the family then as
for how gwynevere fits into this well
she was gwyn's second born child who
like many other deities left in orlando
she would then meet with a flame god
flan and later become his wife besides
these two gwen had two other children
but we'll have to wait for dark souls 3
to discuss more about them so in orlando
the city of gods this place that was
supposed to be seen as a beacon of hope
to all within lordran is just an
illusion but anor londo isn't the only
illusion of lordran but making our way
to the painting inside the city upon
touching it were thrown into the painted
world of ariamis ariamus as a concept is
fascinating as it's this world within a
world and these people inside the
painting could possibly never know of
the world outside of it from exploring
this hidden world we learn that ariamis
was made for things the gods feared
ariamis is home to the followers of
velka and velka is known as the goddess
of sin furthermore this is the only
location in the game where you can find
the dark ember which according to its
item description is used to make occult
weaponry weapons that were favorable
amongst those who plan to kill the gods
and their kin velka was more than likely
someone who wanted to hunt the gods but
was killed or thrown into the painting
it's clear that this place has a
malicious history behind it but it's not
all bad as the person who watches over
ariemus is crossbreed priscilla
priscilla is a half-human half-dragon
crossbreed due to this unique birth she
also gained some unique abilities mainly
the ability of life hunt which she uses
on her scythe these powers of hers could
threaten the gods rule so they also
threw her into the painted world but
what's rather interesting is priscilla
herself she's the only boss in the game
that doesn't want to fight us she even
tells us how to leave ariamus meaning
not only does she have no intent of
enacting revenge but she knows how to
leave yet refuses priscilla may have
felt how these new arrivals feel but
instead of using vengeance she uses
acceptance and instead welcomes these
people into her painted world it's
actually quite wholesome and is the
reason why i couldn't kill her every
boss in this game is hell-bent on
killing me so when i finally discovered
one that didn't want to and in fact help
me i couldn't refuse so i left with the
hope that priscilla would be able to
make this place a proper home for her
people this whole area is swarming with
hollows and other creatures that want
nothing more than to kill us but they
were either tricked into here or thrown
in because the gods willed it and yeah
some of them probably do belong in here
but if priscilla is set on making this
place a home for those who have found
themselves here then who am i to
intervene after acquiring the lord
vessel when we meet with koth or frampt
they'll tell us that to gain access to
gwyn we must gather the remaining lord
souls and use them to satiate the lord
vessel these lord souls belong to four
individuals seeth the scalus the witch
of izalith nito and the four kings three
of whom you will have already recognized
from here we can tackle the game in any
order we want so let's start with the
four kings the four kings are well
four kings who ruled over new londo they
were given fragments of gwyn's soul
which is why we need to kill them you
may recognize their boss location as
this is the same dark abyss that we met
kathan well long ago the four kings were
tricked by koth and were consumed by the
abyss this caused the kings to go mad
and this also caused the citizens to
either become these blobs of mass or the
dark wraith soldiers this area really
utilizes the environment to tell its
tail as this place is overrun by the
ghosts of the villagers and when we
actually unlock the door to lower new
londo we see piles of corpses scattered
throughout the land koth single-handedly
destroyed an entire city simply by
tricking its inhabitants and unleashing
the abyss upon them while the mass
extinction of a city sounds bad there is
still more destruction to be seen one
thing you may have noticed is a severe
lack of human bosses quailag would
probably count as the first one you'd
meet although she's sort of half human
but there's a reason for this as this
has to do with the witch of izalith
while gwyn was frantically running
around trying to figure out what to do
with the flame the witch of izalith had
a plan she was going to create a new
flame that would replace the first flame
but she attempted to create a replica in
the presence of the very thing that was
created which brought with it massive
consequences the witch of izalith wanted
to create a new first flame but there
was already a first flame present in the
world there can't be two first flames
due to this the flame that she created
couldn't be contained for long causing
it to erupt and this not only consumed
her and her children but also created
new life as it gave birth to demons the
asylum taurus and capra demon roughly
the first three bosses in the game were
created from this event in fact anything
that has the word demon in it is most
likely derived from this flame of chaos
but not only was new life created old
life was altered all of eisele's family
who were caught in the explosion were
all transformed into demons themselves
chaos which quailag the fair lady and
ceaseless discharge are three of
izalith's children just as gwyn was
desperate to continue the age of fire in
an attempt to keep what he had so too
did izalith but the consequences are a
reflection of her actions in an attempt
to give life to something bright and
warm she ended up giving life to
something cold and dark she also wanted
to extend the age of fire in order to
continue her prosperous life with her
children but by doing so she ended up
making their lives a living hell not a
single person in this family tree is
living a robust life anymore quail egg
and her sister the fair lady are half
demon and are more than likely suffering
from their condition as told to us by
the fair lady
what is it
quite like
my dear sister
the eggs
it hurts
they've gone still
i am afraid
it may be too late
i am so sorry
dear sister
cecilia's discharge was covered in lava
source from birth so his life was a
living hell from the start the flame of
chaos just made it worse cesalo's
discharged just like priscilla doesn't
actually want to fight us it's only
until we steal this clothing set that he
attacks us this clothing set rests upon
a grave that belonged to his sister
kweilana who he believes died in the
explosion when in fact she was the only
one who escaped quelana will appear in
blighttown if the player is sufficient
enough in pyromancy quelana explains
that she was the only one who made it
out of the reaches of the flame of chaos
in fact she was actually able to harness
the power of the flame of chaos and
create magic which we know as pyromancy
quilana wants us to fulfill her duty for
her as she does not have the strength to
go on she instructs us that we need to
put down her siblings and her mother so
that they may rest in peace this whole
family dynamic is horrific as ceaseless
believes that all his sisters are dead
even though kualana is alive and quelana
is only a few meters from her sister and
yet we can tell her about this clearly
this is turning into a very depressing
story but it only gets worse as we get
closer to the final boss of the area
we'll meet with a pyromancer who is
assumed to be another daughter of izalit
although it's unclear why she is so far
down in these ruins yet is completely
unharmed it's possible that she like way
lana escaped the flame of chaos but this
daughter came back to finish off the
boss right behind her or has possibly
gone insane and is now defending said
boss and by going down this slide we
will meet this monstrosity who is the
bed of chaos this is the witch of
izalith one of the four most powerful
people in the world has been demoted to
this deformed tree-like creature there
are also these orbs next to her that we
need to destroy in order to damage her
and it's assumed by many that these are
her other two daughters that were
closest to her when the flame erupted so
we have two daughters stuck to their
mother two daughters who were half
afflicted by the flame a son who is
arguably the most affected and two
daughters who manage to survive one who
doesn't have the strength to carry on
anymore and another who sits outside her
mother's arena this is by far the most
depressing story i've ever had the
misfortune of uncovering the further we
push into lost izalith the more of the
family we get to meet allowing us to see
the consequences of her actions we can
see the pain that all of them are in as
some of them are just wishing for their
siblings back and others just want to
stay alive it's an awful story that all
leads to the final fight with izalith
herself and it is by far
the most
anticlimactic ending i've ever
experienced it is agreed upon by many
that the bet of chaos is the worst fight
in dark souls 1. the boss is insanely
difficult but it's not the difficulty
itself that's the issue it's why the
boss is difficult i would argue that
just within the main game the two
hardest bosses are the four kings and
ornstein and smoke ons are difficult
bosses because there's two of them you
have to have both on screen at all times
or you'll lose this fight this is
balanced by having ornstein be fast but
not as lethal and smo being slow and
hard hitting it's a wonderful dichotomy
that makes for a satisfying fight and
the four kings is a dps check as every
30 to 45 seconds a second king will
spawn and this will keep going until 4
on your screen at once to succeed you
need to kill the current king before
this happens both boss fights are hard
but have weaknesses you can exploit the
bet of chaos has none to defeat the boss
you need to destroy both orbs on her
sides then go down the middle inside of
her so you can find the source of her
power she's actually extremely weak as
both the orbs and her die in one hit
it's getting there that's the issue her
hand attack is oddly timed and due to
her design it's unclear where her hitbox
ends after defeating one of the orbs the
floor will start to crumble so not only
do you need to avoid her attacks but
you'll also need to avoid the floor
there's also a strict path you're meant
to follow for this fight which will lead
you right next to a broken piece and the
flooring so you'll more than likely get
hit and fall in and die the walk back to
this boss is also just as atrocious as
you'll more than likely spend more time
walking to the boss than actually
fighting her thankfully there is no
reset involved in this boss as every
single run you've done is carried over
to the next as it essentially has
unlimited checkpoints it's like from
software knew it was bad but still kept
it in even if i actually enjoyed the
fight the payoff narratively isn't worth
the time we ventured further and further
into the depths of lost izalith coming
across all of her children who were
these hideous beasts that did incredible
damage and she's just a puzzle the witch
of izalith has one of the best
backstories in the game as the tale of
her children is heartbreaking and being
able to see their conditions face to
face does take a lot out of you but it's
completely soured by a boss fight that
is mechanically and narratively a
letdown our third lord soul belongs to
grave lord nedo and he's interesting to
say the least nito might have the most
detailed boss design but the most basic
story out of all the four lords if you
were to just assume that mito simply
became the grim reaper and just
administered death you wouldn't be far
off which is a shame for someone of his
importance grave lord nido lives in the
tomb of giants which is accessed via the
catacombs both these areas share a
similar theme of death as this is where
the dead are buried so we know that he
administers death but what else does he
do well
not much else he does have a covenant
that you can join but their goal is just
to spread more death across the world it
seems like he doesn't care about what's
going on in the world as the only reason
he attacks you is because we're
obviously here with malicious intent
leader doesn't have any lore regarding
his life during the age of fire and it's
just about him administering death from
this we can infer that nito either
doesn't care about the age of fire or
maybe even just wants the age of
darkness to occur the only other bit of
lore surrounding him is a boss named
pinwheel who is a necromancer presumably
made up of three people as referenced by
the number of masks on the body who
stole an item from him known as the rite
of kindling there are quite a few
theories regarding pinwheel like the
fact that pinwheel was originally a
father but his wife and child died so he
attempted to resurrect them but it
failed and some have stated further that
he's still trying to figure out how to
revive them as we can see skeletons
throughout the room which could be seen
as his test subjects but other than that
we've pretty much discussed all of nito
there isn't anything else to speak about
which is a real shame his backstory has
a massive amount of potential but it
just felt unfinished there are no major
themes tied to nito he just kinda exists
our final lord soul belongs to seath
descales seath as we remember allied
himself with our four lords and attacked
the dragons the reason he did this was
because seath unlike the other dragons
was not immortal all the other dragons
had impenetrable scales that could not
be broken with any type of weapon sheath
was not born with these scales so in a
sense he was not immortal it was only
until gwyn was given their weakness from
seath which we know is lightning that
gwyn was able to pierce the dragon's
scales and actually kill them seath was
envious of his brethren as they had what
he didn't so as thanks for working with
gwyn he was named the duke and given the
duke's archives as well as some of
gwyn's lord soul for power during the
war seath found the primordial crystal
an item that gave him temporary
immortality but during this time in the
duke's archives he eventually went mad
with his experiments in his research he
is considered the grandfather of sorcery
as well as the creator of these
creatures and the moonlight butterfly
our first interaction with seath is that
he ends up killing us and throwing us in
a prison cell we can see that theme of
desperation as seath is trying
everything he can to get what he wants
but in the process it made him mad he's
not as mindful of his actions as he used
to be in a sort of a shadow of his
former self one thing i find interesting
in this prison is the abundance of
miracle-related items and the clothing
that are scattered throughout the prison
it's possible that clerics were deemed
suitable subjects for seath experiments
maybe this is due to their magical power
or because they were so easy to defeat
to kill seath though we need to head to
the crystal caves which i was originally
going to say was probably the worst
level in this game due to half the map
being invisible but the walk to the boss
is surprisingly straightforward
venturing off that path though is where
the problem lies to defeat seath we need
to break his primordial crystals that we
can sever his immortality giving us a
chance to kill him the story of these
lords caused a bit of an imbalance
throughout my playthrough you can go
through lost izalith and the demon ruins
which is filled with rich lore tons of
backstory and compelling bosses that fit
with the lore surrounding the witch of
izalith but then you go to the four
kings and just find out that they were
lords of new londo who got tricked by
koth and consumed by the abyss it feels
jarring going from one to the other as
one feels thorough while the other feels
incomplete like you missed something or
there was more that should have been
said i don't think every boss needs to
have a multi-page wikipedia article in
order for it to be considered a good
story i think that the boss's story said
what needed to be said in regards to the
overarching plot but i can't lie to you
and tell you that i didn't leave these
locations wanting more i wanted to know
more about the four kings and how they
rose to power and i wanted to know more
about nito and sith in general but i
never got that and i guess in a way this
could be viewed as a positive as i
didn't walk out of these places not
wanting to learn them at all but rather
wanted to learn more the game invested
me so much into its story thanks to its
characters and environmental
storytelling that i wanted the game to
provide me with more information on it i
wanted to be encapsulated by this story
more than i already was as with many
souls games not all answers are
explicitly told to us but there were
still a lot of burning questions i had
that never got mentioned with the lord
souls on the vessel we are now able to
fight gwyn but we still have one final
location we need to visit which is the
land of oolacile accessed by the
artorius of the abyss dlc the one and
only dlc that dark souls 1 would have we
start this dlc by defeating this gold
golem that has a woman named dusk
captured inside dusk was the princess of
a place called oolacile according to her
it's a place from an age that existed
long ago hilariously enough she doesn't
actually say anything after this you
would think that the dlc would sort of
spin a story that her home is in danger
and we need to save her but she doesn't
actually tell us that she just sells us
sorceries the dlc doesn't officially
start though until we return back to her
location with an item called the broken
pendant which causes us to get sucked in
into this portal and taken to oolacile
as dusk said ulysses was a place from
long ago and while you may be confused
on how this fits within the geography of
lordran this place is a lot closer than
you think in fact we already ran through
it to get to the dlc the dark rouge
garden is oolacile this is evident by
the tree enemies who have a similar
design to these tree-like enemies and
the same plants that are only found in
the dark root garden are also found here
as well oolusio was a city hundreds of
years before the dark rouge garden came
to be so something happened that made
this place turn into the garden that we
know of well to understand the story of
ulysses we need to talk to elizabeth but
princess dusk is here no longer
snatched away by that horrifying
primeval human and so i must ask
could thou once more play the savior
an abyss was begat of the ancient beast
and threatens to swallow the whole of
ulysses
knight artorias came to stop this
but such a hero has neary a murmur of
dark without doubt he will be swallowed
by the abyss
overcome by its utter blackness
indeed
the abyss may be unstoppable
still
i have faith that princess dusk may be
rescued yet this prime evil human is
manus of the abyss the final boss of the
dlc and the thing that sucked us into
ulusil in the first place so our job is
to hunt manus down my main gripe with
the dlc is justification as technically
with the lord vessel we can just leave
so why do we need to worry about this
it's not an immersion breaking problem
but it is a shame while traveling to the
land of ulysses you will come across
this coliseum-like structure which is
where we get to meet our next boss
artorius of the abyss artorius was one
of the four knights of gwyn the other
three are hawkeye goth who is sitting at
the top of the tower right next to the
coliseum karen who appears in the
coliseum after we defeat artorius and
the final light is orenstein each of
them were skilled in their own ways as
hawkeye used his powerful grapo to shoot
down dragons in fact he can actually
help us shoot down calamite who was the
last of the ancient dragons ornstein
also used his spear that was able to cut
through the scales of dragons with ease
and we can also see the spoils of his
war due to the amount of dragon heads
that exist in anor londo artorias is
also able to wield his greatsword with
incredible finesse and cairn used her
two daggers to cut down anyone who
opposed gwyn's rule but all of them
minus orenstein are way past their prime
which is a growing theme amongst the
entire series goth was imprisoned in
this tower with nothing left to do but
to make carvings he also couldn't use
his grape bow anymore as all the dragons
have been wiped out so he has no purpose
karen may have had a deep love for
artoria says when we visit her she is
next to a grave she made for him and
asks if we can give her his soul if we
do she gives us her weapons and
continues to sit by the grave implying
that she no longer wants to be a knight
anymore and artorias came to ulucio in
attempt to stop the abyss from spreading
but ended up losing and being corrupted
himself his left arm is also dangling
which might suggest that it's broken
this is because he used his shield to
protect his wolf companion sith the same
sif from the main game although he is
much smaller in this dlc sif also has a
different intro if you do the dlc first
because oolacio is in the past so he'll
remember you in the present and it makes
killing him that much harder in regards
to sif it's possible that he doesn't
want us getting the covenant of the
abyss ring as that allows us to travel
through the abyss to kill the four kings
and given his owner's condition siff
probably doesn't want us to end up like
artorias the artorious boss fight was
actually really entertaining he was the
first boss that felt like the antithesis
of this game's combat most of the game's
pace has been very slow and methodical
but he has these fast attacks and very
few openers i do wish though that there
was at least an ounce of build up to
this fight as you can literally start
the dlc and be at the boss room in about
10 minutes i think having the player
traverse some of the areas that are
covered in these abyss creatures that
grow in number as we get closer to
artorias would have been great as it's
slowly leading us towards this person
responsible for all this death well
narratively it felt a bit too fast for
me the fight mechanically was great
after artorias we can explore the rest
of uliseo and we can see how much this
land has been affected by the abyss as
all the inhabitants have been infected
by this dark energy turning them into
these disgusting creatures eventually
we'll reach the bottom and this feeling
of fear starts to set in as the world
becomes darker and darker the further we
go down here in the chasm of the abyss
is where the darkness reaches its peak
and it's where these dark sprites of
humanity live these are very similar in
design to the actual humanity we consume
in game this seems to be humanity in a
more physical form one that is more
exposed and not constricted by the dark
side at the foot of the chasm is our
final boss manus the father of the abyss
menace has an interesting story
apparently the people of ulysses were
tricked by a serpent who was probably
coth into digging manus grave up in
doing so it caused manus to go wild and
unleash his wrath upon them according to
his soul manus was once a human but
became father of the abyss when his
humanity went wild and now he eternally
seeks his broken pendant the same
pendant we had to find to start the dlc
it's unclear why he liked this pendant
so much but it was possibly nostalgic to
him or was given to him by someone he
loved and because this pendant was so
important to him he did everything he
could to get it back which inevitably
drove him to insanity it seems that he
got so desperate to find the pendant
that he pulled in random people into
this world as the npc marvelous chester
is clearly not from this world and he
even says so himself he also kind of
looks like the hunters from bloodborne
which is a nice reference to the game
the main question many within the
community have though is who was manus
before he became his current deformed
state well we really don't know many
have said it's the furtive pygmy and i
like that idea but i think it's less
interesting than that many of the spells
in this dlc say that they were created
by an oolacilian sorcerer on the brink
of madness i can't help but think that
this is perfect for manus description
one thing that is interesting is that in
the middle of the arena is a grave with
a humanity-shaped hole so maybe manus
was one of these humanity sprites when
he died or that this is what he turned
into when he died regardless it's a very
interesting detail i also couldn't get
any footage of this as she disappears
when he leaves the boss room but dusk
apparently appears out of manus when we
kill him meaning that he kidnapped her
this may confuse some people as dusk has
been sort of all over the place in this
game and due to her going from the past
to the present it sort of screws with
the time a bit it seems like she was
sent into our time somehow and was
captured by this golem she then
disappears and goes back into her time
which then leads the abyss incident with
the people of oolacile artorias is then
called to defeat the abyss but fails and
then we get summoned into this world via
manus hand then save dusk and go back to
the present it's still a little
confusing and the world of dark souls is
also very confusing when it comes to
time as always during this fading of the
fire time is very convoluted because we
can summon people as phantoms and the
time sort of stops it's very confusing
but that's how i think it went down but
with manis dead we have officially
finished the dlc however this won't be
the last time we'll hear of manus but
that's for dark souls 2. artorias of the
abyss was a great dlc while it does lack
in motivation and regards to the player
the actual story of the dlc was great it
provides us with a nice timeline of
events as well as more insight into the
abyss and its effects on the world and
while not known at the time it would
eventually set up the plot to dark souls
2. it is without a doubt a worthy
extension to the game's story but now we
can finally go to the kiln of the first
flame and determine the fate of lordran
the kiln is coded in ash and we can see
the spirits of those who followed gwyn
into the kill and walk around aimlessly
as we approach the first flame we have
one person in our way and that is the
lord of sunlight himself earlier i said
gwyn sacrificed himself to rekindle the
flame and he did but because of his lord
soul's power he was able to keep his
body but his mind was gone gwyn has gone
hollow and while i'm more than capable
of killing it myself i couldn't dare
start the fight without the guy who's
been by my side since the very beginning
solaire of astora is easily the most
well-known npc in the entire souls
franchise and his story is a perfect
representation of the mood this game is
trying to convey throughout the whole
game we've been meeting with npcs of all
kinds some with goals and others without
but none of them have managed to touch
my heart in a way that solaire and
siegmeyer did both of them had a goal in
mind one wants to find his sunlight and
the other wants to explore the world but
both are stuck sigmar always seems to be
getting himself caught in some situation
whether that be a locked gate he can
enter or a poison swamp he can cross and
solaire can find his sunlight they both
willingly became undead in order to
achieve their goals and it tore me apart
to hear that sigmar couldn't see it
through sigmar prides himself on being a
knight of katarina and that he can
handle all of his troubles on his own
but with my help i showed him that he
wasn't a worthy knight after all and
that he always needed someone to rescue
him more often than not in these games
your assistance will lead to their death
so it's either converse with them and
enjoy their company knowing that they
will die because of you or distance
yourself from them knowing that while it
hurts it's better that they get to live
another day npcs of these games will
usually end up achieving a terrible fate
but this sadness makes the few times a
happy outcome occurs all the better
solaire wasn't able to find sunlight of
his own he became depressed and wondered
if this journey was really worth taking
conveying the tone of the entire game is
our journey and our struggle really
worth it in the end which is why i owed
it to him to make it right it may not be
the actual sun but the first flame could
be considered the sun so for one final
time i summoned solaire and we took down
lord gwyn
gwyn's theme has such a fitting tune all
these bosses have these intense sounds
with loud music but guinness is such a
simple piano it's not intense it's
almost sad in a way that the most
powerful man in the world has been
reduced to nothing and what was supposed
to be a glorious fight between two
warriors really isn't it makes it all
the more worse when you realize that
gwyn can be parried and once you nail
this timing down this fight is a cake
walk further showing how far from grace
he has truly fallen with gwyn defeated
we can now choose our ending but we
aren't the only one who is able to
choose since we managed to bring solaire
all the way to the end of the game he
was able to also fight gwyn in his own
world thanks to the convoluted timelines
of dark souls and it is canonized that
he succeeded and linked the flame in his
own world he became the sunlight he was
searching for and that might be one of
the greatest endings in the entire
franchise but while solaire linked the
flame that doesn't mean we have to if we
choose the age of fire the world
continues we rekindle the flame and use
ourselves as kindling to continue this
age of fire if we instead choose to
leave we let the flame extinguish itself
we join the primordial serpents
including koth and probably frampt and
usher in an age of dark one where
humanity is at the top and we ourselves
are the ruler at least that's what we
think will happen like many plots on the
soul series this is once again left up
to interpretation we only get to see the
very beginning of our choice so anything
after is just pure speculation who knows
what will happen after and who knows if
our choice was really the correct one
that's always been up to the player to
decide but i've always felt that these
endings are about comfort do we stay
comfortable knowing that in the age of
fire we aren't on top and might be
mistreated due to our lack of strength
or do we take the risk and see what the
age of dark is about one thing to note
though is the circumstances regarding
these endings fram says that the undead
curse will be cured if we go with the
age of fire and not even koth says
anything about this when we talk with
him about it so does that mean that
we'll stay undead or at least still have
the risk of going hollow in the age of
dark furthermore the age of fire was a
time ruled by the gods and they did what
they could to keep it that way but we
killed them everyone in anor londo that
is a god is either dead or gone
gwyndolin is the only one that
canonically lives thanks to dark souls
3. so even though an age of fire can be
seen as the age of gods that might not
be true anymore as we took care of most
of them so there is positives and
negatives both ways and that's really
been the point there's never going to be
a clear answer it's just whatever you
think is right as for me i think an age
of dark is the proper way to go as we
said in the intro the world of dark
souls is like a set of operations things
come and things go and the age of dark
should have followed after the age of
fire but due to gwyn breaking the rules
of the world that didn't happen so i
think in an attempt to set things back
on track before further destruction an
age of dark is the way to go regardless
of what happens in this age of dark at
the very least things will transition
back to the way it was supposed to be
however that might not be the actual
ending given the future titles some have
debated on proper endings and given the
status of dark souls 3 linking the flame
i think is the real ending and is
definitely the most agreed upon as just
about every person in this game will
speak about linking the flame we only
hear about the age of dark from koth who
we have to jump through several hoops to
just even meet i can almost guarantee
someone has gone throughout the entire
game and didn't even know that an age of
dark was the real option because of how
hidden it is and while it's not my
preferred ending continuing the age of
fire would set in motion numerous events
for us to discover dark souls 1 was a
fantastic experience from start to
finish and while the road was a little
bumpy sometimes along the way it's story
wrapped up wonderfully it's a game that
i recommend you play at least once in
your lifetime as you will never get to
experience something like this ever
again but we're just getting started
dark souls 2 is a brilliant game it
takes into account the age of fire in
the age of dark and asks the question
why there are only two options and then
continues this idea by shutting out both
ages by making something else the main
plot of the story something that i will
explain throughout this video so without
further ado
let's get started so before we start
talking about the story we need to
address the game as a whole dark souls 2
requires a different mindset in order to
grasp what the game is trying to tell
you as we saw in dark souls 1 the game
relied heavily on the cycles of the
world to be the main plot it's all about
the age of fire in the age of dark and
what these cycles mean how they impact
the world and what age we'll choose when
we get to the end this means it also
relies heavily on the world itself dark
souls 1 was about our four lords how
they rose to power and what they did
with that power and what the state of
the world is because of said power as
such we play a very insignificant person
in regards to the overall world but dark
souls 2 isn't like that it's not about
the age of fire and the fate of the
world it's about one kingdom and how
this one kingdom handled its own cycle
wardram was important as it was the
first kingdom in the age of fire but
drang lake isn't important at all it's
just one of the hundreds of kingdoms
built on the same land and that's what
makes dark souls 2 so special it's the
insignificance of this game that makes
it so compelling because it isn't tied
down by the world's pantheon it uses
what dark souls 1 created as a way to
write its own story this game isn't
about the cycles it's about one small
part of the cycles the undead curse and
the quicker you realize that dark souls
2 is reshaping the proverbial mold that
is dark souls 1 the better this game
gets but to explain why we need to start
playing our opening cinematic shows our
character collapsing in a rainy forest
the narrator talks about the undead
curse and how it will infect your mind
how it has the ability to remove all
that you hold dear and all that you
remember with every minute the curse
gets worse and worse until you go hollow
as that is the fate for all undead but
this narrator speaks of a kingdom called
durang lake and how we'll walk towards
its gate without ever knowing why we
know why we're here in drang lake as our
character is trying to find a cure for
the undead curse so they no longer feel
its effects but they're unsure of why
during lake specifically just as the
mind gravitates towards the smell of
food when hungry the mind of the undead
is drawn to souls and drang lake has
plenty of them to get to drain lake we
must cross a lake and enter a portal the
scene tries to portray this event as
some marvelous spectacle but that
couldn't be farther from the truth once
we cross this gate we're never coming
back we'll either be trapped here until
we cure the curse or go hollow the gate
is even surrounded by bright bugs which
are known to comfort the dead almost
like it's luring us to our deaths so for
one final time we gather our thoughts
and jump
on the other side of this portal is the
things betwixt a place stuck in limbo
that serves as a connection between
drang lake and the outside world like i
said we're stuck here for good inside
this limbo is a house of women three of
whom are fire keepers that are being
cared for by their housekeeper and
they're very honest about our arrival
you're finished
you'll go hollow
yes
you'll become one of them
hollows prey upon them
feast upon their souls
this is the fate of the cursed
[Laughter]
we aren't the first undead to walk
through their doors and we won't be the
last and all of them have met the same
fate so what makes us any different dark
souls 2 tries to set in this feeling of
hopelessness something that's very
consistent throughout the trilogy no one
truly believes we can accomplish our
goal but that's what makes the emerald
herald so wonderful she believes that we
can succeed in our goal and will help us
in any way that she can and by providing
us the means to level up she might be
the most helpful person in the game this
is why the level up ladies of the
franchise have always been seen in such
a positive light they don't discriminate
and they don't bother questioning if
what we're doing is working they have an
undying motivation to help us succeed
regardless if there's something to gain
from it they're like a bright light in a
dark tunnel as all around them are
people who have given up i am sulden
and like you
i lost everything
and now i'm here
the location they both reside in is
majula a small town on the outskirts of
drang lake and it's the music displays a
feeling of peace a place that is void of
death a place that you can feel
comfortable in and in the world of dark
souls a place like that is more than
necessary i've always preferred when the
main hubs were seamlessly integrated
into the world something that would be
eventually lost with the series going
forward as it makes the world more
believable and in the case of majula
without it you'd be missing this
beautiful scenery after taking in the
view we can speak to the emerald herald
who will reveal our objective seek those
whose names are unutterable
the four endowed with immense souls
these four beings are known as the four
great ones the lost sinner the old iron
king the rotten and the dukes deer freya
just like before we have four beings
that need to be slain in order to
continue and just like dark souls one
how we go about killing them and in what
order we want to go in is entirely up to
us but one thing to point out though is
that the emerald herald isn't a fire
keeper at least she wasn't originally
her real name is shenalocht and she was
given this name by the dragons her
purpose was to break the undead curse
but seeing as there is thousands of
hollows in draeng lake she clearly
failed her goal now is to just rest at
majula guiding the undead on their
journey to succeed king vendrick before
we go though i want to talk about the
npcs i think dark souls 2 really dropped
the ball when it came to these
characters many of them are extremely
forgettable and seem to only be placed
in the worlds that the player can be
given a tangible item rather than an
engaging story benhart of jugo is a good
example as he seems like a compelling
character that may have a memorable
quest all for it to crumble almost
immediately his whole questline revolves
around his family heirloom the giant
teal sword resting on his shoulder which
you may recognize as the moonlight
greatsword except this one is a fake it
doesn't have the magical properties of
the original but benhart believes that
with enough strength he can unlock its
true power i would have dropped this
quest entirely if it wasn't for the fact
that he gives us the sword at the end of
it he provides a little to no substance
to the world and this goes for a vast
majority of characters we meet there are
over 40 npcs in this game and about 90
of them provide the player with a
service and some of their services are
either outclassed or completely useless
lenocraft is the majula blacksmith but
the player may find mcduff another
blacksmith except macduff can do
everything lenograss can do but with the
added bonus of being able to infuse
weapons and gevlon is a lonely merchant
who only sells five items four of which
are poison he also has three set
locations so in order to purchase his
services you'll need to go out of your
way to find him and that's if you really
want poison equipment there's just so
much clutter as half these characters
could literally just combine into one
general goods merchant thankfully it's
not all bad lucatiel has a wonderful
questline as she shows us the horrific
reality that is the undead curse she was
a warrior of mira but now she barely
remembers who she is by the time we get
to the end of her questline she's
practically pleading for us to remember
her name as she may not remember it
herself it's unclear why she came to
drang lake in the first place but given
that her brother aslutil will invade us
only a few feet from her final location
it's possible that she was looking for
him but now both of them have succumbed
to the curses affliction never truly
knowing what happened to the other
thankfully lucatiel isn't the only
character of note in this game as the
feud between creighton and pate and the
peaceful conversations with vengara were
fantastic being able to take the role of
a detective and truly uncover which one
is telling the truth and then choosing a
side before one prevails was a great
investigation and the fact that a
talking head can get me to listen to his
life's story as he thinks about his past
life and how much he despises it shows
me that this game has some wonderful
stories that are just waiting to be
uncovered you just have to weed through
the dozens of merchants in order to find
them getting back on track we're still
on the hunt for the four great ones once
again this is similar to dark souls 1
but instead of ringing the bells of
awakening and then finding the lord
souls we just have to find the souls
already if you remember from that video
on dark souls 1 i said that the bells of
awakening section was a bit slow as not
much in terms of plot was happening it
wasn't until we rang them that the story
really started to take off well in dark
souls 2 it's the same unless you look at
the bigger picture before we get to the
four great ones there are a lot of other
areas we need to go through first for
example to get to the lost center we
need to go through majula to hayde's
tower of flame to no man's wharf through
the lost bastille and then to center's
rise where the boss is located all these
locations will seem pointless and if you
just only do this boss fight it will
continue to feel like that it isn't
until later in the game when the climax
hits that things start to make sense no
man's wharf is a small port town and its
final boss is the flexile century the
century's job was to take as many undead
as they could fit on this boat and send
them to the lost bastille which is a
prison for the undead but this isn't the
only location to have lore regarding the
curse the huntsman's cops was a hunting
ground for the old iron king's men who
were tasked with killing any undead on
sight but as you would expect they too
also succumb to the curse next to this
area is the undead purgatory where a
chariot rider continually kills and
punishes the undead it's also possible
that these necromancers were purposely
stationed here this may imply that the
necromancers were used to resurrect the
undead so that they can be repeatedly
killed for entertainment like i said
this game does not focus on the cycles
of the world it's all about the curse
and this is only discovered once we get
further in the game but in the beginning
it may seem a bit overplayed that's why
it's required to have a different
mindset going into this game if you're
thinking about the cycles and this
game's lore will be boring and
repetitive but it's actually brilliant
once everything comes together as these
early areas are showing how different
rulers are reacting to the curse and
what their actions are as a result of it
and speaking of rulers one of them
happens to be one of the four great ones
the old iron king resides in the iron
keep but to get there we must pass
through the huntsman cops which we know
is the place the old iron king sent his
men to hunt the undead behind this
location is harvest valley and earthen
peak two areas that are coated in poison
thanks to one individual mytha the
baneful queen but this story is rather
tragic she wasn't originally like this
monster we see today she was a beautiful
queen but her drive to win her beloved's
heart back is what drove her to such
lengths myth's story though does have
some complications she has named both
queen and princess and that she loved a
prince and sought the king's affection
her story is very confusing because we
don't really understand whether she was
a queen and a princess or just one of
them but whoever this person was it's
clear they did not love her and thus she
began using poison as a way to obtain
beauty but this came with its own set of
problems as the poison started turning
her into a snake-like monster and yet
while she was sulking around her room
day in and day out trying to win the
heart of a man she unknowingly already
succeeded in doing just that the
covetous demon was a human who loved
mytha and cherished her no matter what
form she took he tried to showcase his
love for her through gluttony but this
too would change him and turn him into
the monster we see today but despite his
change in appearance his love for the
queen never wavered behind the poisonous
swamp of earthen peak is the iron keep
home of the old iron king the old iron
king was a lord of very little power but
he would then eventually meet a knight
called sir elon who trained his soldiers
in the art of battle the old iron king
would then eventually build his kingdom
but doing so cost him almost all his
assets but one day he discovered an iron
producing miracle this allowed him to
control iron to his heart's content
which led to the iron keep a giant
fortress made entirely of iron he
started creating soldiers made entirely
of iron and even a demon of fire called
the smelter demon this idea of creating
things a free will with only raw
materials is also related to the undead
chariot which of course was his creation
so he's quite familiar with this craft
eventually for whatever reason sir alone
would leave the iron keep and set out in
search of unknown lands after losing his
most trusted knight the iron king sought
the council of a man named agel he was
presumably a pyromancer due to his goal
of trying to give fire a will of its own
the two worked together to create the
aforementioned smelter demon but this
would bring disastrous consequences to
the keep the two never considered that
by giving something free will it has the
chance to turn on its creator and the
smelter demon did just that with one
swing it obliterated the iron king and
sent him into the lava it was born from
this act also caused the lava to take on
a much larger form and crash into the
iron keep consuming it in lava as we see
now but while the keeping its soldiers
were scrambling to higher ground
something else happened the iron king's
body came in contact with an old soul
the old king's soul to those in the
present day he is known as the one who
shall not be named but for us
we know him as gwyn when killed the old
iron king will drop the iron king's soul
but it's only on new game plus that we
uncover the truth that the old iron king
has come to possess the very soul that
gwyn possessed all those years ago but
the old iron king isn't the only one
each of our four great ones has come in
contact with a soul that belonged to a
notable character from the past game but
not only did it give them strength it
may have also carried with it the
emotions of those it belonged to both
gwyn and the old iron king share a theme
of power gwyn wanted to keep his
god-like power and as such took multiple
steps in order to achieve that like
linking the first flame branding
humanity with the dark side and tossing
things he felt could threaten their rule
into the painted world of ariamis and
while his feelings weren't as fierce as
gwyns the old iron king also desired
power he wanted to ensure a protected
and impenetrable kingdom while also
relishing in the power that comes of
being a king so he used his power to
create a giant kingdom with skilled
knights and dozens of monstrous
creatures made from iron and then
displayed his power by tormenting the
undead for sport and torturing them
endlessly simply because he could but
while the iron king tortured undead
against their will there was one person
whose torture was self-imposed located
in the center's rise underneath the lost
bastille is a prisoner who willingly
imprisoned themselves for the sins of
their past according to shalakhar
majula's resident feline her sin was
that she tried to light the first flame
but the key word is light implying that
it had already gone out so how would
this be considered a sin if anything it
would be the opposite sadly we never
truly know what any of it means one
thing we do know is whose soul she
possesses before the boss fight starts a
bug crawls into her eye specifically a
chaos bug the same one from lost
lazalith she is in possession of the
witch of izalit's soul we know that
these bugs have mind controlling
capabilities as evidenced by the bad
ending of solaire's questline so it's
possible that the lost sinner intended
to let us into her cell until the chaos
bug felt threatened but that still
doesn't answer the question regarding
her self-imprisonment maybe she wanted
to keep the chaos bug and in turn her
from escaping as this crazed version of
the law center could have run rampant
and slaughter dozens of people or maybe
she's somehow feeling the emotions of
izalith who probably felt immense guilt
for creating the bed of chaos so maybe
this feeling of guilt is being
transferred over to the lost center
without her knowing to this day it's
still a mystery but a very compelling
one at that the witch of izalith had a
desire to create life which is why she
wanted to make a new first flame but she
wasn't the only one who had desires but
that being's legacy may have created
even more devastation than intended the
duke's dear freya is a spider who is in
possession of seath's soul but seath's
feelings and desires are able to engulf
those who come in contact with it
freya's soul talks about a writhing ruin
and how this ancient thing casts a
shadow over the land and that at some
point in its life it came in contact
with a solitary insect but grew its
power feasting on the wealth of twisted
souls found within the land if we defeat
freyja we can enter the lord's private
chambers which houses the duke of
seldora himself and a cage that
presumably belonged to freya the
writhing ruin was created from seat's
intense feeling of want he searched
endlessly for a way to be immortal even
when he was plagued by insanity and it's
because of how powerful his desires were
that they seemed to linger on past his
death the writhing ruin would go on to
possess others in an attempt to obtain
something as he possessed a being that
turned man scorpion tark and his wife
into half-human creatures it has this
insatiable urge to achieve something
what that something is will depend on
the individual seath wanted immortality
and freyja may have just wanted strength
or power regardless this writhing ruin
will presumably seek something until it
doesn't for eternity and ruin many lives
in the process it's obvious by now that
there seems to be a parallel between our
old cast and our new ones in regards to
their feelings and emotions whether they
receive these similar feelings when they
came in contact with the old souls or
the souls were attracted to them because
of their feelings is unknown but our old
friends legacies continue to bring
disaster even after their death but for
one of them that may not be the case our
final great one is the rotten in medjula
there is a giant pit and assuming you
can get down there without dying you'll
arrive at the grave of saints a catacomb
that used to be a burial site before it
was overrun by rats i was admittedly a
bit confused running through here as i
thought this was some ongoing joke i
wasn't aware of as there's a literal rat
talking to me calling me his servant in
the most serious tone possible it's
pretty pointless and it's best if we
ignore it and moved on but sadly we
won't be doing much moving as much as we
will be falling dark souls 2 somehow
managed to surpass blighttown and
quality by making the gutter a darker
version of blighttown all while being
poisoned thanks to these statues just
like blighttown the lore is quite
similar as these are the citizens of
various kingdoms that were tossed away
out of sight from the rest of the world
after the gutter is the black gulch the
home of the rotten the rotten possesses
the soul of nito but instead of their
emotions being similar it seems to just
be their appearance nido was an
amalgamation of skeletons and the rotten
is an amalgamation of dead bodies but
whereas nido was hell-bent on
administering death throughout the world
the rotten seems to sort of embrace or
comfort it these statues might possibly
be the people who have died down here in
the pits he might be trying to comfort
these hollows in their new life and
these statues seem to be a showcasing of
his feelings towards his new community
what is rather odd though is that these
statues in the boss room don't shoot
poison at us so it's possible that they
weren't meant to shoot poison originally
and it's because of this poisonous rot
that has taken over the pits that
they're allowed to do so throughout our
discussion about the great ones you
obviously notice the connections between
our old and new cast of characters but
you may have also noticed the lack of
lore there is a lot of information that
is either completely unclear or only
given some amount of weight thanks to
the abundance of theories from the
community dark souls 2 is both the most
understood and most confusing game
within the trilogy it just depends on
what answers you're looking for however
i feel like i'm content with this one
thing that bothered me about dark souls
1 as we discussed before is that i left
some of these boss arenas with more
questions and answers i wanted to know
who the four kings of new londo were and
how they rose to power i also wanted to
know more about nito and his role in the
world after the war with the dragons and
while i definitely have similar
questions regarding some of our great
ones i left majority of these areas
feeling complete like i had learned what
needed to be learned and i uncovered the
real story and that's the benefit of
creating something like dark souls 2. we
don't really need to know what these
great ones did and how they shaped the
fate of the world because they didn't
despite how important many of the
characters in this game may seem at the
end of the day they're just another
kingdom in a long line of other kingdoms
no one is going to remember them and no
one is going to care about them that is
why i feel satisfied when leaving the
black gulcher center's rise i've
uncovered enough lore to get a generous
picture of their life with a few holes
just big enough for me to make some
solid theories with all four great ones
slain we can now go to drangleic castle
or
can we
this is aldia the brother of king
vendrick and the scholar of the first
sin aldia's story is very unclear at the
moment but we'll eventually learn more
about him later once we enter drangleic
castle we'll see this phantom by the
name of welliger he's a sort of lore
dump which admittedly might not be the
best way to handle this information but
given the nature of these games where
you can go a whole play through without
really knowing anything maybe it's
necessary regardless welliger shares
with us some backstory on drayng lake
and vendrick king vendrick conquered
four great ones and built a kingdom upon
their very souls he then met a lady
named nashandra who warned vendrick of
another looming threat these beings were
known as giants king vendrick could
eventually cross the seas and battle
these giants completely decimating their
civilization as a consolation prize he
took most of them prisoner and ran
experiments on them this is what led to
the creation of the golems these beings
we see inside the castle and with the
golems he was able to build drang lake
castle later in the game we'll acquire
this item called the ashen mist heart
this allows us to peer into the memories
of some specific beings most of these
memories are from dead giants we come
across in the first level these all
showcase different sections of drangleic
being overrun by giants and one of them
even shows us the location of the giant
lord we'd see the destruction that they
left during lake castle in and we can
also see how outmatched the soldiers
really were even though they outnumber
them three or four to one they're
getting decimated at every turn but
somehow they were able to persevere
considering there's no giants in draen
lake but i think the person responsible
for some of this victory is us these
memories operate like oolacile from dark
souls 1 where we go back in time to
alter the past and then go back to the
present this may tie into a subtle hint
very early in the game the first boss in
dark souls 2 is the last giant whose
boss soul description reads the lord of
the giants who had brought wreck and
ruin to the entire kingdom was said to
have been felt by an unknown warrior his
beaten and broken remains were then
dragged beneath the stronghold where he
was sealed away this random giant soul
references the giant lord and also
describes the exact condition this giant
is in meaning this giant is the giant
lord and that must mean the unknown
warrior was us this might explain why he
thrashes his arms around trying to break
free as he remembers us and wants
revenge this is the complete backstory
of drang lake which gives us enough
answers to our questions but
simultaneously gives us new questions we
want answers to such as the whereabouts
of nashandra well close to the top of
the castle is the queen herself the last
king of this land
king vendrick
as he was called
he found the strength to rule his people
and when the undead were born
cursed
he found more strength to face them
but in the end he never took the true
throne
visit vendrick
we have no need for two rulers
so nashandra wants us to find king
vendrick as she says there is no need
for two rulers but she also mentions
that king vendrick never took the throne
she just casually says this statement as
if this isn't some huge revelation since
gwyn people have been rekindling the
flame but vendrick didn't but that
doesn't mean vendrick wants to bring
about an age of dark he doesn't want
either this is even more unheard of as
no one has even attempted to invoke a
third solution to the fading of the
first flame but to learn more we need to
find vendrick he resides in the undead
crypt but blocking our path is two
bosses the looking glass knight and
velvet stad the royal aegis both of
these fights were fantastic both from
the actual combat to the design of the
bosses i'm just upset that it took this
long for this feeling to finally come to
fruition i rambled for quite a bit about
the bosses in dark souls 1 like how
ornstein and small were fantastic and
how i despised the bed of chaos but i
haven't found the right time to talk
about the bosses in dark souls 2 as
there really isn't much to say most of
them are pretty underwhelming for the
most part and this is down to a few
factors one was simply over levelling
since dark souls 2 has 32 bosses in the
main game it's very easy to miss some i
didn't find the chariot or old dragon's
lair until much later when i revisited
those areas so i was a bit over prepared
for the boss fight dark souls 1 had a
really great way of getting the player's
progression while also guiding them down
a path which in turn made every fight
feel like a proper match it wasn't a
one-sided victory for the most part
there were a few exceptions like
gwyndolin and pinwheel but they have
very low health pool so it's a bit hard
to judge them the other two reasons are
just down to overall enjoyment and the
summons the majority of the bosses in
this game not only have summitable npcs
but multiple at that i had two summons
for the looking glass knight and while
the game does attempt to balance this by
adding more health we all know the main
strength of the summons is to be an
extra body for the boss to hit which
means less attention on us and more time
to get free hits in i will admit this
trivialized many fights the smelter
demon the rotten and probably a few
others were really easy with summons but
that comes to my next issue to complete
some of these npc questlines we talked
about earlier they need to be summoned
for bosses as someone who's trying to
get as much lore as possible in one
playthrough i needed to continue these
summons questline so while i was gaining
more progress with the npcs it came at
the cost of the quality of the fights
this makes me even more disappointed as
many of these quest lines didn't even go
anywhere so they were just completely
useless and wasted my time some of the
boss fights though just sucked
regardless i was pretty disappointed
with chariot fight even though it was a
cool idea i just wasn't a big fan of it
and this game's obsession with gang
fights is quite insane the ruined
sentinels and the belfry gargoyles were
just not entertaining in the slightest
ornstein and smoke only worked because
of how different they were in regards to
their moveset and how the arena was
designed and the bell gargoyles were
okay for the most part since the second
one didn't come until halfway plus they
used different move sets the ruined
sentinels were the same enemy copied
three times with zero obstacles to
separate them minus the one platform you
start on and the belfry gargoyles got
way out of hand with close to three or
four at the same time in the same arena
as the original fight which is not that
large and very open i did manage to beat
them on my own so i was happy that i won
but only because i knew i'd never have
to do that fight again as for the four
great ones the old king was just awful
even though i had a summon with me his
moves would have been the same
regardless and they were almost too easy
to evade the other three were pretty
good but nothing spectacular they did
provide some intense moments but i did
have to summon lucatiel for two of them
so i may have missed some of that
spectacle i will recognize though that
this entire section is a very subjective
take as a boss's enjoyment largely
depends on the skill of the player and
their build but since this is all about
my thoughts on the game my opinion was
that they were pretty underwhelming for
the most part it felt like instead of
focusing on fewer bosses with unique
engagements they created more but at the
cost of their depth behind the looking
last night is the shrine of amana and
the aforementioned undead [ __ ] each of
these places were created specifically
for the dead both the milfonido and the
finito watch over these respective
places in an attempt to guide the undead
to their final destination both of these
creatures have interesting backstories
as they were created by the old dead one
who we know as neato both of them seem
to be a reincarnation of nido's soul as
if he created them we would have seen
them in dark souls 1 but maybe they
didn't plan that far ahead when making
the games regardless it is a nice detail
and finally gives us some actual story
regarding neato so i was more than happy
to listen to it it also continues to
reinforce the old one's soul
descriptions that mention how their
souls still hold power over the land as
the power of nito and his obsession with
all things death are still utilized to
this day as for what they specifically
do it seems like the milfenido enchant
or comfort the dead via song as their
singing can be heard throughout the
level and the finito are grave wardens
who watch over the dead both of these
groups seem to revolve around comforting
the dead so maybe nito was a lot more
like the rotten than i had initially
thought at the very end of the crypt is
velvet's dad and while the boss fight
was great what really piqued my
attention was his soul and the items
acquired from that soul firstly his soul
is a dark purple and black color this is
the same as the dlc bosses from dark
souls 1. i originally thought that this
was made to distinguish the dlc from the
main game but it wasn't until dark souls
2 that i realized that the soul's shape
has actual meaning this is an image of a
normal bossel in this game next is from
one of the great ones and the other is
of those affected by the darkness both
manus and the royal aegis have the same
soul meaning they're both affected by
the darkness and that's due in part to
him being down here since vendrick
locked himself away in the crypt another
detail that is interesting about
veldested here is that his soul can buy
miracles specifically the sacred oath
miracle which is used by warriors who
once served the god of sun so it seems
like the royal aegis belonged to the
same covenant as solaire however we can
see that this miracle has either been
warped or is unable to be casted as he
never actually uses this in the fight
and instead buffs himself with dark
magic further showing how dark his soul
has become after the royal aegis we can
meet vendrick and if you expected some
grand entrance then you're playing the
wrong game
just like when the most powerful being
in the game's world is reduced to a
hollow and mindless state vendrick's
condition actually seems to be much
worse as gwyneth retains some of his
combat abilities but vendrick can barely
swing his sword if he choose to fight
him all is not lost though for our king
as if we return with the ashen mistart
we can peer into his memories and be
able to talk with vendrick prior to his
hollowing do you intend to link the fire
then you must first take the throne
prove your worth
find the ancient crowns
seek adversity and they will be yours
vendrick tells us to seek the crowns
these crowns belong to three rulers and
also happen to be r3dlc these dlcs not
only provide us with additional lore
regarding other kingdoms but also what
caused these kingdoms to collapse when
we finish each dlc we can gain a crown
and after obtaining said crown we can
talk to vendrick for more dialogue some
of the dialogue is relevant later but a
common theme throughout his speeches is
the idea that we're given a choice all
throughout dark souls 1 we were told to
link the flame and that if we failed the
age of dark would arise and that would
be the end of the world but king
vendrick is more than content with you
making your own choice this goes back to
what we discussed before vendrick didn't
want an age of fire or an age of dark he
just wanted to find a way to break the
curse this also ties into his brother
aldia and some of his dialogue when we
meet him again
all men trust fully
but is this so wrong
the construction of assad and yet
definitely the most fascinating
character in this game like vendrick he
is completely aware that he is unable to
change the world in their current state
so he just observes and sees what
happens aldia says that the joy of life
is warm and splendid but it's a facade
as the undead curse will eventually come
back but because of that warmth that
life brings us are we intent on
shattering this illusion we live in and
spoiling this false life we have or are
we content with our lives and embrace
the warmth and pleasure that comes with
it knowing full well that it's a lie
aldia just like the game wants you to
actually make a choice and not blindly
follow what some random person will tell
us use your own experiences your own
knowledge and your own beliefs to come
to an answer the way this was crafted
was absolutely brilliant and it shows
how impressive the writing of this game
truly is but before we get to the dlc
and obtain the crowns we need to talk
about the rest of the content as to
actually get the ash and mist heart item
we need to travel to aldi's keep in the
dragon shrine both aldia and vendrick
sought to cure the curse but had
different methods of doing so vendrick
shunned the undead as he wanted them as
far away from the kingdom as possible
that's why he threw them in the undead
prison of lost bastille in here are
hundreds of undead including some
volatile variants as these were created
by aldia whereas vendrick shunned the
undead aldia embraced them as he felt
the key to breaking the curse was within
the undead themselves but he didn't
welcome them with open arms as they were
all subjected to his various experiments
but aldia went even further with these
tests and didn't just focus on the
undead but other species he even
recreated multiple dragons a race of
beings thought to be extinct by now
despite what their names imply though
both the guardian dragon and the ancient
dragon aren't actually dragons the
guardian dragon soul can allow us to
purchase the drake wing greatsword which
states that the drakes are likely
descendants of ancient dragons this
implies that this is actually a drake
and not a dragon furthermore we know the
dragons especially the original dragons
are gone as kalameet was the last of the
ancient dragons this is still true as
the ancient dragon in dark souls 2 isn't
a dragon as it drops a soul of a giant
this thing used to be a giant and was
somehow configured by aldia through
rigorous experiments to look like an
ancient dragon to get the actual ancient
dragon soul we need to use the ashen
mist heart again but this time in
freyja's boss arena as it allows us to
see the memories of the dead dragon
hanging from the ceiling this memory
seems to show the original resting place
of this dragon before it somehow made it
down here there's not a whole lot to
learn from this place other than the
fact that these large broken structures
look similar to the ones outside aldia's
keep there's only one place in the world
that we know that has giant structures
like this it is my belief that this is
ash lake it might not be the entirety of
ash lake as we don't really know how far
these trees went but it seems to be at
least some part of it in regards to time
this is most likely during the war
between gwyn and the dragons ash lake
existed back then but it wasn't the ash
lake that we're familiar with as if you
remember it was all gray before fire was
born so the memory was during the war
with the ancient dragons and the present
day location of aldia's keep is where
some part of ash lake used to be with
all the areas covered we can head to the
dlc and it's advised to finish all the
bosses and content you missed before
going which is why i retrace my steps
and discover the locations of the dark
lurker and the old dragon slayer i
didn't really find their stories that
interesting but i figured i would cover
them before we continue the old dragon's
lair seems to be someone who is using
orenstein's armor as a way to uphold his
legacy as not only does ornstein have
other plans which we'll learn about in
dark souls 3. some have claimed that
this is a fragment of orenstein's old
soul that now possesses the armor which
would connect with the running theme of
old souls from the past games coming to
the present just like with the four
great ones as for the dark lurker
there's pretty much nothing we know
about this being at all their soul
states that they're a remnant of some
ancient dissipated being and the color
of their soul is not dark implying that
they weren't born or consumed by the
abyss like the royal aegis or manus they
also look very similar to these beings
in the undead crypt that spawn when the
bells are rung given the color of the
dark lurker's soul it's possible that
this being was actually here to fight
against the abyss similar to artorius
but there is very little evidence to
support this theory but now we can
officially start the dlc dark souls 2
eventually release with three additional
pieces of content the crown of the
sunken king the crown of the old iron
king and the crown of the ivory king
given the disjointed nature of these
dlcs they could be played in any order
as they don't contradict one another but
we'll just go in the order of release
the crown of the sunken king starts near
the shrine beside the rotten's boss room
and entering the shrine will take us to
shovel the sanctum city upon entering we
are greeted by not only a gorgeous view
of the underground city but also a
dragon with a giant spear through its
chest this dragon is sin long ago a race
of people found sin sleeping in these
caves and because they had most likely
never seen a dragon before they
worshiped him as a god these people
ended up building a city around the
dragon with the rulers of the kingdom
being the sunken king and his queen
alana but something happened a leader by
the name of sir yorg found the
underground city and mounted a siege
against its inhabitants with the
intention of slaying the dragon they
were guarding sir jorg and his knights
believed that killing dragons was a way
to obtain a true understanding of life
so they hunted it down after making it
past all their defenses sir yorg was
face to face with sin himself and that
giant spear in his chest was from him
but clearly sin lived this wound and
that's because upon awakening from his
slumber he released a giant cloud of
poison that coated the entire city that
may also explain why the black gulch is
covered in this poisonous green liquid
since it's right next to the city but
there's no way to confirm before we
fight sin though we have to fight alana
so somehow despite the poison and the
attack from sir york she managed to live
well this might be due to her true form
according to her boss soul and weapon we
can piece together that when the abyss
dissipated it was broken into fragments
and eventually these fragments came to
create a life meaning that elana is the
daughter of manus the reason the abyss
was broken was that the chosen undead
defeated manus back in dark souls 1 and
since he was called the father of the
abyss that would make alana his daughter
clearly she poses a threat to more than
just shova so we need to put her down
after her death is when we gain access
to sin as a final fight sin wasn't too
bad his unique mechanic where the poison
from his breath can break the durability
of your weapon which could possibly kill
the entire run if you're not careful the
only issue is that this seems to do an
insane amount of durability damage as my
banded axe with only 50 durability was
destroyed in a few hits i'm not entirely
sure if 50 is on the low end of
durability but going through all the
weapons i picked up across my whole
playthrough they were all between 40 and
70 so if anything i should be right in
the middle this wouldn't have been that
bad though if sin didn't act like the
guardian dragon and just stayed put for
more than a few seconds i think you
could see from the gameplay the amount
of chances i have to actually hit this
thing are extremely low i think what
makes shovel so engrossing is the
location how do you possibly build a
giant civilization underground and for
what reason that's at least what i was
thinking when going into the dlc and
while i got my answer i wasn't entirely
satisfied with it one reason why is down
to dialogue is there is no npcs in this
dlc to talk or converse with we can't
gain any new information as all the
people that could have been npcs are now
just walking corpses given that sin
poisoned the whole city i wonder if
adding one npc at the very beginning of
the level who's the only survivor of the
attack would have been a better idea as
they could have provided the player with
additional information surrounding the
city such as why they worship the dragon
or how they managed to build all these
structures because in its current state
it feels a bit unfinished the crown of
the old iron king is our second dlc and
is of course based around the old iron
king from the main game this dlc takes
place in one of the largest towers he
erected called the broom tower to find
the crown we need to traverse the entire
tower all the way down to the bottom
which was incredibly tedious there were
a lot of traps and enemies that can be
very annoying to deal with but given
that the dlc seemed to want to spike up
the difficulty these additions kind of
made sense this tediousness also added
to the realism of the level as it takes
quite a long time to scale this entire
tower which is logical given its size
and the tower itself isn't just empty
space as all the space is being used for
some sort of purpose whether it's the
smaller guys carrying these giant
barrels or the vast amount of machinery
within the tower that was made to
produce iron it also fits in well with
the theme of the old iron king's
obsession with iron and how he gained a
lot of power from his production of iron
this dlc however adopts the same
storytelling as the sunken king and that
there are no npcs to talk to throughout
the entirety of its run time but what
makes the broom tower different from
shova is that we already have numerous
levels and items filled with lore about
the iron king shovel was a completely
new area with zero reference to the main
story which is why i enjoyed it a bit
less regarding the npc interaction than
the broom tower even though the first
boss is technically another smelter
demon the real first boss is actually
the fume knife i have zero issues
regarding this fight i actually thought
it was perfect i've stated this many
times before but i prefer the fast
combat of the future from soft games as
opposed to the slower more methodical
nature of the early souls games it's not
that one is objectively better than the
other it's just a personal preference of
mine and just like with artorias and
manus the fume knight is another boss
that is slowly ramping up the speed of
its attacks they aren't incredibly fast
especially by modern souls game
standards where a 10-hit combo can be
finished within mere seconds but the
fume knight is definitely a far more
faster paced fight compared to the rest
of the game and this even continues with
the other boss in this dlc which is sir
elon it's just like the other boss
fights of this game where you have to
look at your health stamina and both
your and the boss's positioning all at
the same time and then calculate what to
do given the parameters except much
faster i understand this is not
everyone's cup of tea but it's most
definitely mine and even better the fume
knight has actual ties to a previous
character from the main game king
vendrick had two trusted knights who he
considered his left and right arm one
was valdistat and the other was the fume
knight however the two clashed which led
to the few night's defeat what's
interesting is that if you defeat the
royal aegis purchase his helmet and then
wear it during the fight the fume knight
will start his second phase almost
immediately showing that he still has a
grudge against him as for the fume
knight himself he wandered the land in
search of power and eventually came
across the broom tower and met nadalia
the bride of ash nadalia would have been
the queen of the old iron king but she
arrived at the keep after he died she
fell into a deep despair because of this
and ended up separating her soul across
the broom tower inside these ashent
idols which caused the tower to be
covered in this thick black fog this fog
has the power to control those who wish
to serve her and kill those who refused
when the few net arrived instead of
destroying the fog like he could have
done he actually just opted to be
consumed by it which is why he sits at
the bottom of broome tower defending the
remains of nadalia since she has the
ability to create this black fog and her
soul is colored in darkness it is once
again safe to assume that she is another
daughter of manus if you're noticing a
theme here then you're catching on to
the point of these dlcs each one of them
is centered around a kingdom that a
daughter of manus inhabited and this
goes for our final dlc but before we
leave the broom tower there's a secret
room we can discover with sir elon's
armor and by using the ash and mistart
we can go back in time to when he was
stationed at the tower this leads to the
boss fight we discussed earlier but it's
a memory and if we take what we know
about the memories and apply it here we
can discover even more lore about sir
elon if we assume that the unknown
warrior that best of the giant lord is
us since we went back in time then we're
also responsible for killing sir elon so
that statement i said earlier about sir
elon leaving to search for new lands was
possibly a lie as it may have been told
by the old iron king so that his
soldiers don't uncover his true fate
which makes things a lot more sinister
than they seemed our third and final dlc
is the crown of the ivory king the ivory
king was the ruler of the kingdom elaim
loyce upon entering we can see that it
is covered in snow and given that there
isn't any snow in draen lake we must be
pretty far from the original kingdom as
we approach though we are told to leave
this voice tells us that the old chaos
still hungers and that we are forbidden
from entering clearly we're not gonna
listen and charge headfirst through the
front gate eventually we'll meet with
the first boss of the dlc ava this is
one of seven pets that the ivory king
kept in his kingdom each one seemed to
have a specific role in the kingdom as
ava was tasked with guarding the king's
child of dark this child of dark is
alsana and as you would expect she is
our third daughter of manus but her
story is a lot less destructive when
alsana was born she felt fear this is
because she was a manifestation of manus
fears all the daughters of the abyss are
a manifestation of something nadalia
seemed to be manus despair elana was
possibly a manifestation of manus wrath
and alsana was his fears but when alsana
was born the king managed to find her
and welcomed her into his kingdom he
provided the comfort she desperately
needed and was kind enough to not shun
her away even after he discovered her
true origins it's because of this
kindness that she stayed in lam lois and
continued to fulfill the ivory king's
wish which was to hold back the old
chaos the old chaos is the flame of
chaos the same one created by the witch
of izalith it's unknown when this was
discovered by the ivory king but once he
did find this ancient monstrosity him
and his fellow knights set out to
extinguish it but they were defeated as
none had come back alsana wants us to
defeat the old chaos so that we can
uphold the mission of the ivory king to
do this though we're going to need some
other knights of elaine loyce as they
are absolutely necessary if you want the
fight to be possible once we're all set
we can jump down into the old chaos
again just like we did with lost izalith
and this boss is absolute perfection few
fights in the souls games actually get
better with summons and the ivory king
is one of them i felt like i actually
had to apply strategy to an encounter
which was the first time the series has
required me to do that i don't mean
strategy in the sense of reading the
boss's moves and making sure how to
punish and win as that's just baked into
the overall combat of the encounters but
i mean the actual decision making i had
to employ such as which enemy to attack
and when which was something i did not
expect i would be doing going into this
fight i was running around finding
knights who were outnumbered and
assisting them or if it was the opposite
side of the spectrum i would add myself
into the mix making the fight easier
this is almost necessary for the fight
as well since you're going to be doing
the most amount of damage compared to
all the other knights so your decision
in this fight will largely impact how
the second phase will go i'm not
entirely sure if the knights can die in
the first phase given they have an
obscene amount of health but if they can
it just further adds to my point having
two giant teams of warriors fighting
against one another is one of the
greatest things i've ever experienced
and is without a doubt the best fight
this game has to offer from the actual
fight to the layout of the arena which
is engulfed in the fire from the flame
of chaos it was just all perfect and
would have been such a great way to end
this trilogy of additional content but
never in my life have i seen a dlc do so
well all throughout the entirety of its
run time only to fumble at the finish
line the frigid outskirts is an optional
location that the player can discover
towards the end of the dlc and it is
awful it's not only painstakingly
difficult just from the design alone it
might actually be the worst level in any
souls game ever made the bonfire before
entering the coffin is the only bonfire
in the area meaning you have to go from
one end of the map to the other just to
get to the boss fight which is just two
more of the ivory king's pets their lore
is thankfully super basic and not
important at all as their job was just
to hunt exiles that were presumably sent
out of the kingdom and into the frigid
outskirts this area would not be nearly
as hard if the horses didn't keep
spawning every few feet not only wasting
your time but draining your estus in the
process making the boss fight that much
harder it's just an awful location and i
think the more that i talk about it the
closer i get to going insane so we're
just gonna cut it right here as a
complete package the dlcs were pretty
solid there were things in each that i
found a little unpleasant like the
method of storytelling or an entire area
but there was many things i liked about
the dlcs and due to this confliction i
can't say that together they're perfect
but they're nowhere near close to being
bad it's hard to judge though whether
this was an actual improvement over
artorius of the abyss considering that
was one dlc with half the content that
played out over half the time this is
also due to the souls games business
model if people complain about anything
regarding the dlcs of the souls games
it's that they're too short rather than
too long whereas many games like to make
additional content with run times of up
to 6 to 20 hours dark souls is pretty
much content with two it never overstays
its welcome in fact it sometimes leaves
too early and doing this gives us less
time to learn about the dlcs in the
locations they reside in but as i said
at the top of the section as a complete
package they were pretty great with all
the crowns in our inventory we can
revisit vendrick who will now provide us
with some very important dialogue
the abyss once had form
but then dissipated
and yet traces of its existence endured
each fragment thirsting for power spread
dark with no relent
my dear chandra was one such fragment
so we now know the fourth and final
daughter of manus the chandra the queen
of draen lake the chandra is a
manifestation of manus feelings of power
and want she came to this land in order
to covet the first flame this explains
why vendrick was in the undead crypt
vendrick left the kingdom because he
discovered nashandra's true origins and
not only locked himself away in the
crypt which was guarded by one of his
loyal knights but he also hid his soul
as vendrick doesn't drop this upon his
death it's hidden behind a secret door
only accessible to those who are human
and nashandra never truly was that's why
she's been so adamant that we succeed
vendrick she figures that we'll blindly
follow her order so that we can clear
all the obstacles in her path because
once we finally get to the throne of
want and defeat the knights guarding it
she appears similar to the ivory king i
found this fight leagues better when the
summons were included mostly due to the
narrative aspect since both benhart and
vengarl were helped due to me so it's
only right that they return the favor
her boss design is impeccable and
continues to uphold the standard that
the final bosses of the game have but
not even nashandra is the actual final
boss
aldia is the actual final boss assuming
you fulfilled a few tasks along the way
which is just meeting him a few times in
specific locations and then specifically
killing vendrick before nashandra as a
final boss fight though it felt like a
bit of a letdown i think nashandra had
way more intensity and narrative weight
behind her aldi has been this ominous
figure that just shows up says a bunch
of [ __ ] and then leaves and now all of a
sudden i'm supposed to care that we're
fighting him i get why he's fighting us
he's supposed to test our might to see
if we're truly going to be the next
monarch of the throne of want but that
doesn't make it right the same could be
said for nashandra given she makes an
appearance a whole two times in this
game but that seemed to be intentional
as the reveal of nashandra was supposed
to be this mysterious event which makes
this next part even more confusing as
the emerald herald can literally spoil
for us that nashandra will be coming for
us i completely missed her on the way
down so i never got to hear this which
ultimately made the impact of this
cutscene hit harder which begs the
question of why it was mentioned in the
first place i find it hard to believe
that many people miss nashandra at the
top of the castle so they're well aware
of who she is so just keep the mystery
hidden until the final moments it kills
the entire impact of the scene if we're
just told right before entering that
she's gonna fight us after the defeat of
the three bosses we can select our
ending and while this game does have two
endings what these endings represent is
rather interesting our first ending is
entering the throne of want this is sort
of like the kiln of the first flame just
a little bit different it allows us to
choose the fate of the world but we
never get to see our choice it is both
the age of fire and the age of dark
ending together it's never known what
our character chooses but that's the
part of the role play when it comes to
rpgs we make up the rest of the story
did our character choose fire did they
choose dark or did they do something
else and that something else is
following in the footsteps of vendrick
and aldea we leave the throne and search
for an answer to the undead curse we
don't know if we'll succeed but it's
worth a try anyway doing this is sort of
like operating a dig site yeah vendrick
and aldia spent decades digging trying
to find a solution and failed but now
thanks to them we know of a decade's
worth of methods that won't work
bringing us closer and closer to finding
a cure for the curse and that's the
beauty of the second ending it's not
only in perfect sync with the rest of
the game as it continues to make the
curse the main plot of the story but it
gives us an option that we as players
hadn't really considered up until this
point dark souls did a phenomenal job of
grooming us into believing that there
were only two choices but dark souls 2
refutes this claim and as a third as a
final note dark souls 2 was a brilliant
game i went into this game with mild
expectations but was blown away by how
impressive the story was and how
surprisingly easy it was to grasp many
questions are still left unanswered and
will never be answered but i left this
game with an understanding of its story
its themes and what emotions it had
intended to invoke in me and that is
incredibly admirable but the world of
dark souls isn't over the fire of the
world will fade once more and yet
despite the impending doom of the age of
dark getting closer and closer no one
seems to care
but we'll talk about that in dark souls
3.
dark souls 3 is a perfect game due to
the way a book ends the entire series
but the only reason that i can say that
is because of how much this game is
being held up by its predecessors dark
souls 3 on its own is still a good game
but without all the effort put into the
story from dark souls 1 and 2 its
narrative wouldn't be as impactful
that's the beauty of the dark souls
trilogy it's one of the few series out
there that truly feels like a tightly
knit game many games get sequels but not
many truly feel like a proper sequel
just a game set in the same universe a
year or so after the previous game it
might make callbacks to the past game
but not enough to feel like what
occurred in that game was important the
dark souls trilogy and its repetitive
ideas make the games feel properly
connected the age of fire the undead
curse hollowing and so much more have
been a prominent part of the series
since its inception which is why judging
these games individually based on their
stories is so difficult as each of these
games relies on each other to actually
make their story have an impact dark
souls 2 and 3 could not exist without
dark souls 1 and not just because of its
world building and important characters
but because it's the game that showed us
what the age of fire is and why it's
important we then took this information
into dark souls 2 which showed us how
the age of fire is not all it's cooped
up to be and how as all the years go by
people are starting to embrace the fire
less and less this all comes to an end
to dark souls 3 a game that is purely
focused on the age of dark and why the
first flame needs to go each one of
these games provides a crucial step in
our journey and without even one of them
every other game loses its meaning we
already talked about the previous two
games and what they attempt to show to
the player and all these themes ideas
and plots all converge towards dark
souls 3 creating one of the best endings
in a series i've ever seen
and today i will explain why so without
wasting any more time
let's get started so ironically for a
game that's going to be about the age of
darkness and how much death and decay
the current age has caused it starts off
with an incredibly intense soundtrack
it's not even been 10 seconds and this
electrified feeling of exhilaration
seeps into your body dark souls is back
and it's time to kick some ass this
feeling continues right into the intro
cinematic and dark souls 3 weighs 0 time
getting into the story this is the first
time in the trilogy where the game
outright tells you who the main bosses
are which are the abyss watchers altered
saint of the deep and yorm the giant
there is also a fourth that isn't
mentioned but we'll discuss them a bit
later just like before it's four beings
who will need to be dealt with in order
to succeed but instead of them being the
four lord soul users or the four great
ones it's the four lords of cinder the
question is why are they so important
well oddly enough the game tells you but
the pure spectacle of the intro is so
hypnotizing you might not even realize
what was just said according to the
opening narration the bells only toll
when threatened the reason they're being
threatened is because the fire is fading
again but furthermore it's because
someone doesn't want to link the flame
that person being prince lothric since
the prince doesn't want to link the
flame the bells of awakening revived
previous lords of cinder from past
kingdoms each of these aforementioned
beings i mentioned earlier were people
who link the flame in their lifetimes
the bells assume that if they have
linked it already then they'll do it
again but they all refused the
abysswatchers aldridge and yorm don't
want to in the last ditch ever to make
sure the fire is linked the bells of
awakening have awoken other beings who
are unkindled people who have failed to
link the fire in the past but are now
given a second chance and we are one
such person known as the ashen one our
job is to defeat the lords of cinder and
take their ashes to their thrones as if
they won't come back willingly then
their ashes will serve as a substitute
this is the plot of the game no small
objective in between like finding
vendrick or ringing the bells right away
from the get-go we're tasked with
killing these beings and licking the
flame assuming you've played the
previous games already then you've heard
this story twice before and already know
what you're getting into which is why
our first boss isn't even 5 minutes into
the game in dark souls 1 it took around
the same time to fight the asylum demon
but the game also taught us about our
inventory and weaponry but also showed
us that we can converse with npcs and
used in estus flask dark souls 2 took a
bit longer with this as the first boss
wasn't for a couple hours and the basic
tutorial can take a bit of time to run
through in dark souls 3 we start with
the estus flask get all our gear and
start our journey immediately there is
no handholding here as the game assumes
you've done this all before and don't
need much of a refresher the reason why
they put udyx in here is because he's
supposed to test our strength not just
the ashen one's strength but ours since
dark souls 3 underwent some drastic
changes in regards to its combat and for
those who have noticed yes i'm using an
axe again it wasn't until starting this
game that i realized i'd used an axe for
all three of them so i figured it'd be
quite comical if i beat the entire
trilogy with the same weapon before
killing utyx though we'll see him become
engulfed in this black form this is
called the pus of man this is a unique
disease that is taking over the kingdom
and it originates from the abyss similar
to how manus humanity went wild causing
him to become the ferocious beast that
we know in game it's possible that this
is happening to other hollows but on a
much grander scale as this won't be the
last time we see this pus of man in the
game after udyx we can take the coiled
sword from his body and use it to create
the bonfire at the new firelink shrine i
absolutely love the design of firelink
shrine from the moment you walk in and
see all the thrones lined up around the
bonfire you feel a sense of comfort it's
definitely my favorite across the entire
series but i loathe its location
firelink shrine feels so disconnected
from the rest of the world even though
majula was on the outskirts of dragon
lake castle it at least became a nexus
for all the various paths that the
player could traverse to the cherry on
top here is that we can't even travel to
the first location we're forced to
teleport to it it just further shuts
this place away from the rest of the
kingdom there's no incentive to explore
the other areas of the level as we've
already seen everything it has i never
understood why the series slowly moved
towards this idea but it seemed to be a
massive hit amongst the team as this
would be used in other games going
forward from a pure gameplay perspective
the firelink shrine of dark souls 3 also
reverts the changes in dark souls 2 to
keep things more simplistic andre is
back and will handle anything regarding
our weapons from upgrades to infusions
and the shrine handmaid becomes our
all-encompassing merchant so no more
clutter like in dark souls 2. we also
have our new level up lady who is just
the fire keeper she doesn't have any
unique backstory like the emerald herald
but her condition does spark a few
questions it seems that all the fire
keepers have some sort of condition that
afflicts them anastasia the lady under
firelink shrine will initially be mute
and cannot be spoken to the darkmoonitus
in anor londo has a disfigured
appearance which is why she hides it
from us with her armor and this fire
keeper is blind this has always been
fascinating to me as i've never been
able to fully understand why this is the
case it's possible that this is a sort
of rite of passage and the fire keepers
are showing their willingness to the
flame by giving up something but what
they lose seems to differ across the
games it's possible that this is just a
coincidence but there's also an npc in
the game we'll meet called irina who
tries to be a fire keeper and is also
blind fire keepers being blind only
occurs in dark souls 3. so i've always
wondered why blindness is occurring now
instead of across the series it's
something we never get an answer to but
definitely a fascinating topic to
discuss speaking of the characters in
firelink shrine i want to talk about the
npcs though before we embark on our
journey third time's the charm as they
say since the npcs this game are handled
way better than in the previous two
titles my issue with each game is that
dark souls 1 kept replaying the same
fate of hollowing across all of its
characters which started losing its
value very quickly and dark souls 2
seemed to just make characters for their
rewards rather than their stories but
dark souls 3 seems to fix this issue the
quantity of the npcs has been
drastically reduced as they're only
around 27 or so in the main game there's
also very little overlap in the
merchants as each school of magic has
one designated npc with the exception of
pyromancy and while greyrat does have a
pretty useless inventory for the most
part since he's a thief you can actually
send him to find gear which will
increase his options this was so much
better as i didn't have to run around
the base finding the one merchant who
sells the item i need furthermore the
actual quests of the npcs were much more
enjoyable this time around there was 5
standout characters for dark souls 3 but
one interesting change with this game
though is that the npcs connect with the
main content both sigurd and henry have
a connection with a specific lord of
cinder and yurius questline ends up
becoming one of the endings of the game
i really liked this idea as so far the
npcs have been separate from the main
bosses so it was nice to see it all
intertwine with one another it'll be a
lot easier to explain what their quest
lines are alongside the main content so
we'll hold off on this for now which
means the only other two that we have to
talk about that have a more traditional
quest line are irina and cirrus as we
talked about before irina is blind and
this is because she came from her land
of kareem to become a fire keeper you
might recognize the name kareem as
oswald the trek and the marvelous
chester from dark souls 1 are all from
kareem the reason we find irina here in
this cell is because she's filled and
hasn't become a fire keeper yet due to
this failure she believed that she was
unfit to tend the flames and fell into a
deep depression the knight guarding her
is aegon of kareem and has a sworn duty
to protect her no matter her state of
being to progress her questline we need
to buy her spells if we buy her miracles
then we'll be able to give her the
enlightenment she needed and will
eventually become a firekeeper at
firelink shrine gameplay-wise she's
pretty useless in this state is not only
is there already a fire keeper but she's
also hundreds of feet away from the
player as opposed to the actual fire
keeper who is right next to you if we
however only buy her dark miracles we
further progress the ferocity of the
humanity with inside of her causing her
to be consumed by its dark power this
turns aegon hostile who will fight you
for betraying her she will eventually
start to become worried and asks us to
touch her again so that she can tell who
is nearby but eventually she will not
recognize our touch and ask to be killed
it's a genuinely sad outcome and this
emotion is heightened further because
we're the ones that caused it hedy
instead just kept purchasing her regular
miracles we could have saved her from
her impending fate it's a quest line of
two extremes one where she gets
everything she wants and one where she
loses everything and it all depends on
you as for sira she starts out as some
random person who appears at firelink
shrine sir seems to be a darkmoon blade
since she uses the dark moonblade spell
which can only be acquired by those a
part of the covenant but yorshka the
leader of said covenant states that
we'll be the only knight in the group if
we join furthermore sira says that she
is a former servant of the divinity
which may imply that she was a darkmoon
blade but left some time later as for
why she left it seems to be related to
the two people we fight against
throughout her questline who are
creighton and hodrick creighton is the
same one from dark souls 2 although this
does not imply that he was the canon
winner between him and pate as this was
probably thousands of years ago and i'm
assuming that creighton is also
unkindled as he most likely was revived
alongside us cyrus says that creighton
was a part of the rosaria's fingers a
rival covenant and one that she despises
and hodrick seems to be her grandfather
the reason we know this is because she
calls out to him before the fight and
when defeated she says that she's
pleased that her granddad can rest in
peace hodrick seems to have gone mad at
some point and sirius wanted to put him
out of his misery she has a short but
sweet questline and the family
connection to hodrick was quite the
shock the question still remains though
what is the sunless realms because her
full name is cirrus of the sunless
realms it's nice to speculate about it
but there isn't much information to go
off of and this is a running trend
throughout the series and personally
something i'm not a fan of there are so
many locations in the game that we learn
about like astora karim katarina mira
alken venon so many more but there's no
in-depth lore about them hell most of
them don't even give us a service level
idea of what they're about this is not a
dark souls 3 issue and more of a series
issue as the devs have been given three
chances to develop some of these places
and from software has just refused to do
so many people including myself have
tried to speculate on more details
regarding these kingdoms but there's so
little to go off of that it's not even
worth it their inclusion in the game was
probably because the team wanted to add
a bit of flavor to the world to not only
show that the main kingdom isn't the
only kingdom in the dark souls universe
but also that people from all over are
flocking to this kingdom in search of
something important it just feels like a
wasted opportunity to barely mention
these places after three whole games as
a whole dark souls 3 has some great
quest lines and i would go as far to say
that it's the most polished out of the
entire series dark souls 3 recognized
what was wrong with the previous two
entries and made sure not to repeat
those same mistakes again with the npcs
done we can now resume our objective
which as a reminder is to defeat the
lords of cinder and use their ashes as
kindling so that we may travel to the
kiln of the first flame and re-link the
fire to do this though we actually need
five lords of cinder the abyss watchers
yorm prince lothric aldridge and ludleth
the reason i said four earlier is
because ludleth is actually the only one
who complies with the rules as he's
already at firelink shrine when we
arrive loveless throne says that he was
exiled from his homeland the reason why
he was exiled was because of his art of
transposition for gameplay purposes this
allows us to take the boss holes and
make weapons out of them just like the
past games what's odd though is that
when he dies he drops the skull ring
which talks about it being called the
soul feeder and how it was this
insatiable beast that hungered for souls
due to the ambiguity of his past it's
led to many theories such as ludwig
being a soul feeder himself but was at
one point defeated which is why he has
no legs and possibly can't fit on his
throne it is also entirely possible that
loveleth is just someone who wants to do
the right thing and has no ill
intentions but the skull ring definitely
leaves a lot up to the imagination to
get to the other four lords we'll need
to use the bonfire at firelink shrine
which will take us to the high wall of
lothric and it is absolutely stunning
you're immediately greeted with an
entire view of the castle and it's a
breathtaking view but it's also an
illusion the kingdom of lothric is
riddled with corpses and those who
survived other became hollows or are
still seen defending a lifeless kingdom
lothric is governed by the three pillars
of rule the knights who protect the
kingdom the scholars who run the grand
archives and the high priestess who also
served as prince lothric's wet nurse
those who abide by these rules are the
lothric knights but these wingnite
variants are said to be heretics as they
don't accept their rules this is because
of gertrude the heavenly daughter in the
grand archives we can find a birdcage
cell with a dead body in it this is
assumed to be gertrude she was one of
the queen's holy maidens although
depending on some item description she
may also have been her daughter one day
gertrude was visited by an angel and
through this was able to establish the
angelic faith of lothric seeing as this
isn't a part of the regular three
pillars gertrude was taken and
imprisoned those who agreed with her
teachings though band together to defeat
the current rulers of lothric which led
to a massive civil war out of all the
three kingdoms we visited so far in the
trilogy the kingdom of lothric is easily
in the worst state this condition that
we see the castle in may also symbolize
the world of dark souls itself i'll
elaborate more on this idea later but
it's my personal theory that not only
did our characters from dark souls 1 and
2 link the flame but every person in
between these games did so as well if we
go back to the intro the narrator says
that lothric is where the transitory
lands of the lords converge meaning this
isn't like the past games in dark souls
1 all the main bosses were within lord
ren already but in dark souls 3 the
lands of these lords have been forced
together it's unclear how this is even
possible but it may go back to the first
flame the world of dark souls is dying
it's a shadow of its former self places
are being buried destroyed and created
in an endless loop the intro does a
great job of showing this but the one
area that truly opened my eyes to this
was drag heap this place is covered in
rubble and buildings that span so far
and wide that you can't even tell what
the buildings used to be or when they
were built we talked about how time was
convoluted in dark souls 1 but in dark
souls 3 this has been progressed even
further lands are being moved together
creating a tidal wave of rubble and it's
all because the first flame if you
watched the past videos you may have
noticed how worse things have gotten
throughout the series and i believe this
is because the first flame hasn't been
snuffed out people are still clinging on
to that illusion of life as aldia put it
and are willing to stay in the comfort
of what they know rather than step out
into the unknown and because of that the
world has gotten even worse each dark
souls game has tried to push the player
toward one specific idea the age of fire
in one the breaking of the curse in two
and the age of dark and three everyone
in dark souls 3 is just doing what they
continue to do because it's all they
know some are blindly following their
faith and others are continuing to work
on their craft this game truly conveys
the attitude and the effects of a dying
world one that is practically begging to
be put out of its misery it's basically
saying look at all of this in-game look
at the destruction of the kingdoms the
ruins of the world and the people who
inhabit it do you think any of them are
truly happy to be alive right now not
even the lords of cinder beings who have
insurmountable power don't even want to
link the flame it lays all of this out
for you and asks you to choose which is
quite a heavy burden choosing to go
against the status quo that has been
said for who knows how long is a very
hard decision but at least we don't have
to make that choice now as the game will
blinds at us again and create another
boss encounter for us to be hypnotized
by we'll talk about it for later though
as he does have ties to another boss
later in the game after vort will be
taken to the undead settlement this
place functions like the undead burg in
dark souls 1 as this place was the
residence of many of the kingdom's
undead but one thing we'll see
immediately upon entry is this massive
pile of corpses at the end of the bridge
these beings are pilgrims that are most
likely from the kingdom of londor as the
only survivor is yol of londor he is
related to yuria however so we will have
to discuss him a bit later as we explore
the undead settlement we can see that
this place is in just as bad of shape as
lothric castle bodies are piled up
everywhere and some have even been put
into cages this land has also been
subjected to various curses and because
of this many of the settlements
inhabitants sealed them away in a spirit
tree but would end up cursing the tree
itself which would lead to the creation
of the cursed rotted great wood during
the second phase the great wood will
slam into the ground and will discover
the true resting place of all the
settlements hollows in the aptly named
pit of hollows it's unclear though
whether or not the hollows that were
dumped here were alive or not upon
arrival but since the mound maker's
covenant is down here it's possible that
they were thrown in here alive and all
fought to the death which would explain
the plethora of bones covering the walls
but it could also be that these people
actually banded together to create the
mound maker's covenant regardless it's
clear that their fates were sealed the
moment they were thrown in while the
curse rotted great wood is to the left
of the dilapidated bridge if we instead
go to the right we'll make it to the
road of sacrifices and subsequently
fairing keep which leads us to our first
lord of cinder the abyss watchers fair
and keep is rather interesting as not
only is it the resting place for the
abyss watchers but it may also be the
ruins of oolacile in this area we can
find the golden scroll and the dusk
crown items that have ties to ulysil and
we can also find dead mushrooms and
maybe even the final resting place of
elizabeth if this taller mushroom is
assumed to be her this would also fit
narratively with the abyss watchers as
they were a part of an organization
dedicated to fighting the abyss and
seeing his manus was located under
ulysses this would tie together quite
nicely the abyss watchers were the main
fighting force of a group called the
undead legion of pharan who took
inspiration from artorius and dedicated
their lives to fighting the abyss but
their group numbers seem to be much
larger than they seem as these monstrous
beings are seen guarding the abyss
watchers boss arena they even managed to
recruit one of the twin crystal sages
that is said to have betrayed his
scholarly friends of the grand archives
to ally with the undead legion as for
the abyss watchers themselves it said
that they all shared the blood of the
wolf most likely in reference to this
wolf found in the area and used its
blood to increase their power and their
power was unmatched is not only were
they able to hunt together like a pack
of wolves but they've been known to bury
an entire kingdom at the slightest sign
of the abyss this group would eventually
link the flame presumably an attempt to
cast away the abyss for good but with
their main force gone the rest of the
forces dwindled and left the undead
legion as there was nothing else to do
but as we know the abyss can't be
destroyed that easily it eventually came
back and went unchecked since none of
the legion were around and managed to
turn their land into a festering swamp
these monstrosities that we see may have
been legion soldiers who were corrupted
by the abyss when the abyss watchers
awoke they came to the realization that
their home was overrun and their mission
was unsuccessful and while it's not
stated when this happened at some point
some of the members became tainted with
the abyss itself which leads to the
cutscene before the boss fight where
they're all fighting one another as
they're trying to fight back against the
abyss but since they're all undead
they're constantly being revived so
they're stuck in this never-ending
battle between each other which is
likely why they won't link the flame
doing it the first time didn't stop the
abyss and they have more important
things to do than sit on their throne
and let the abyss consume the world i
absolutely love the abyss watchers and
not just from a lore perspective but
also as a boss what really sold the
fight for me was the hints of artorias
that were spread throughout their move
sets the undead legion took inspiration
from artorias so it's only right that
they mimic his fighting style and the
fast-paced leaping attacks that they
have really reminded me of that fight
furthermore this fight's quality
increases tenfold once the other members
join in as it turns this honorable duel
into this chaotic mess you lose all
focus during this fight as you're having
to keep track of three different abyss
watchers who can slide across the arena
in a second and the second phase is just
as deadly as the last dead abyss watcher
consumes the blood of all his brethren
in a last-ditch attempt to stop us he's
a lot faster than last time and produces
flames from his sword which makes the
fight even harder it shows how dedicated
the group is to their mission and how
they'll use anything they can as long as
they win similar to how artorias fought
us with all his strength and even a
broken arm from both a presentation and
gameplay perspective the abyss watchers
are fantastic lords of cinder and the
best way to introduce the player to the
sheer power these lords hold behind the
abyss watchers is the catacombs of
karthus a place that has seemingly no
actual kingdom as this karthus is never
seen in game but given that wolnir is
located down here and is known to be a
lord consumed by the abyss maybe the
abyss watchers leveled the entire
kingdom and while that is an interesting
idea to think about what's more
important is actually what's underneath
the catacombs if we break this bridge
and use it as a ladder we can enter the
smoldering lake the original location of
lost izalith and possibly ash lake in
here we can see giant structures that
look very similar to arch trees of ash
lake and given the geography of lordran
ash lake and lost izalith weren't too
far from one another so it wouldn't be a
stretch to assume that they can exist in
the same location if we continue deeper
into the lake we'll see dozens of dead
demons that resemble the capra taurus
and stray demon from dark souls 1. it's
very clear that the demon race is dying
and that they're struggling to survive
we can even see this in this stray demon
near farron keep which is covered in
stone rather than the flesh and blood
that we're used to there's even the old
demon king whose boss room is covered in
the corpses of his fellow demons he'll
try his best to fight the ashen one with
all his might but most of his power ran
out years ago and as a last resort will
release all his flames in a fiery
explosion but in doing so he'll lose all
the power he's ever consumed and will be
unable to fight the demons of dark souls
3 are a dying race and further adds to
the theme of death and decay the game is
trying to convey kingdoms aren't lavish
spectacles of beautiful architecture
they're a war zone and the demon race is
no longer a formidable foe just a dying
breed that won't last another generation
the symbolism of this place is beautiful
as it shows that everyone is being
affected by the progression of time and
no one is gaining from having this age
continue but not everything needs to
have a sad ending as if we explore the
rest of the smoldering lake we can find
the corpses of a spider and a woman and
judging from the tone that is located on
her body it seems that quelana found the
fair lady and got to spend their last
moments with one another it's a
wonderful and happy ending quelana got
to find her sister who she thought was
dead and the fair lady is finally able
to die and no longer has to suffer
anymore getting back on track to get to
our next lord of cinder we need to find
irithyll but to gain entry we need to
find a specific item that is located in
the cathedral of the deep the resting
place of aldrich saint of the deep
aldridge's story is by far the most
vague but also the most detailed amongst
the lords of cinder as his story
encompasses various other bosses that
we've already had the pleasure of
meeting years ago aldridge was a common
cleric but he would eventually start
experiencing visions of a deep sea this
deep sea was another form of the abyss
and it was located in the lowest
possible depths imaginable and form the
core components of the world we never
get to see the deep sea in game but it
seems to be the lowest layer something
only aldrich can see he then shared this
info with only those he trusted who were
his archdeacons mcdonnell royce and
klimt they not only kept this
information within their inner circle
but also encouraged one of aldridge's
insatiable urges whether this was
something he always had within him or it
came about when he saw visions of the
deep aldrich had an insatiable urge to
consume human flesh the archdeacons
encouraged this behavior and used their
influence to create an army of followers
to not only worship aldrich but also
went out and gathered sacrifices for him
that's why these evangelists are located
in the undead settlement as they are
trying to bring the undead to the
cathedral so that they may be consumed
by aldrich we also learned that he would
eat anyone even including children as
henry and horus are said to be the only
two children who managed to escape
aldridge's grasp where henri and horus
are located happens to be the road of
sacrifices the path that the settlers
and evangelists took to get to the
cathedral before consumption this
cathedral performed all manner of
rituals and cleansings in order to
purify those who entered its doors after
numerous sacrifices the people around
aldrich managed to go insane and even
though aldrich himself was able to keep
his sanity his form would change rapidly
as he would eventually become the black
sludge that we see in the intro due to
his immense power he was used as a lord
of cinder but seeing as aldrich was
fully consumed by the visions of a deep
sea linking the fire would be the
opposite of what he had planned so this
implies that it was linked against his
will they would eventually return
aldrich's body to the cathedral to be
placed inside the large coffin scene in
the deacons of the deep boss fight these
deacons were led by the archdeacons we
discussed earlier but while aldrich was
laying in his coffin another piece was
added to the board pontiff sullivan was
a former resident of the painted world
of ariandel just like the world of dark
souls the painted worlds have their own
cycles that need to be rekindled in a
sense while the pontiff lived in the
current painted world of ariandel but
felt no reason to continue his life here
as he had not experienced any hardship
or despair we'll learn about the
painting's residents in the dlc but
unlike the painted world of ariamis
which was a world for all the things the
gods feared ariandel was for those who
had nowhere else to go and are without
purpose sullivan would then set out in
search of a purpose and would eventually
come across irithyll this place is very
relevant to the story as right next to
it is on orlando the same one from dark
souls 1. from various item descriptions
we learned that gwyndolin didn't
actually die in dark souls 1 as he is
still very much alive in this game now
whether or not the chosen undead never
fought him or they killed him but he
somehow revived himself is unknown and
ultimately irrelevant but with gwyndolin
being the only god left in anor londo he
tried to reach out to those in his
extended family in hopes of trying to
rebuild the god's rule the only one he
managed to find though was yorshka a
crossbreed girl similar to priscilla
it's unclear what her relationship with
gwyndolin was or even her relationship
with priscilla was but all we know is
that she was content with helping
gwyndolin in his objective gwyndolin
would also reinstate the darkmoon blades
as a way to help protect them from any
adversaries one of their knights though
happened to be pontiff sullivan who
infiltrated its ranks and managed to
corrupt all the members he came across
he would then end up enacting his plan
when gwyndolin was stricken with an
illness that left him unable to care for
his covenant or city sullivan in one
successful swoop managed to imprison
yorshka in a nearby tower and throw
gwyndolin inside an orlando cathedral
allowing him to have complete control of
ear though which is how he earned the
title of pontiff in order to ensure
protection of his new kingdom the
pontiff would not only set irretholene
lights in various positions as guards
create a barrier over the whole city so
that no one could enter but also send
outrider knights to conquer other lands
we've already seen a few outrider nights
across the game already but the two most
notable knights are vort and the dancer
of the boreal valley not much is known
about the duo except the fact that the
dancer was a daughter from one of the
royal families in irithyll whether she
served willingly or not is unknown
either way both of their fates would end
up the same as they were both bestowed a
ring given by the pontiff which would
end up slowly turning them into these
malformed beasts after an unknown amount
of time aldrich would reawake again as a
lord of cinder and would foresee the
world's eventual destruction at the
hands of the deep sea due to this
premonition though he would neglect the
throne and wait for the deep to overcome
the world and it was during this waiting
that he would dream of the old gods and
how they wanted to relink the flame he
saw this as a ploy against his own
wishes and sought to devour the very
gods he then traveled to irithyll
decimated the knights guarding the city
and forced the pontiff to surrender who
gave up control of anor londo allowing
aldridge to have an audience with
gwyndolin what happened next is what we
see during the boss fight we interrupt
aldrich mid-consumption who now has to
use the barely conscious body of
gwyndolin as a weapon to defeat us
aldrich seems to have very supernatural
powers as his soul when transposed can
give us the darkmoon longbow which
belonged to gwyndolin but also the
lifehunt scythe that belonged to
priscilla but interestingly though he
never consumed priscilla only dreamed of
her from what i can gather it seems that
aldridge can acquire abilities from
those he consumed and is also able to
peer into that person's memories the
reason he was able to acquire the life
on scythe is because it's a miracle
miracles and dark souls are like stories
you're essentially reciting a story and
using the talisman as a medium for the
power so aldridge consumed gwyndolin and
dreamt of priscilla during the
consumption and then learned the story
of the life on scythe and was able to
cast it since it's basically just the
equivalent of reading a story again
earlier i said aldrich had the most
detailed story out of the lords of
cinder and i wasn't lying his story
doesn't just include himself but five
other bosses and close to a dozen named
characters it is a very long story to
wrap your head around but it is the kind
of storytelling that got me interested
in these games in the first place it
showcases all the different events from
different points of view and how these
characters fit into one cohesive
timeline but just as the story is
detailed so too is it vague the deep
sits on a shelf alongside many of the
concepts of the dark souls universe that
are barely touched upon in its defense
though the deep does have a lot of item
descriptions tied to it so we can at
least get a better understanding of what
its true nature is but seeing as it's
never shown to us in game or ever
elaborated on further than what we
talked about it just becomes another
idea in the world of dark souls that
leaves a lot open to the interpretation
as for the boss fight aldrich was pretty
entertaining but i think a much better
boss fight in my opinion was pontiff
sullivan i've always liked sullivan's
design and plus the walk towards him is
always very ominous as you don't know
what to expect especially when he dashes
right at you the moment you get too
close ford and the dancer were pretty
much on the same level as aldrich in my
opinion i still think pontiff ranks
higher than all of them but they were
really entertaining fights and honestly
this opinion i have is pretty much the
same for most of the bosses in this game
even udyx was an entertaining fight and
he was the first boss we ever face it's
clear that the quality of the bosses has
been raised thanks to dark souls 3 and i
think one reason for this was because
the team reverted the previous ideas of
dark souls 2 and instead focused on the
quality again rather than the quantity
each fight brought some sort of unique
twist so that it never felt like you
were in some traditional fight as that's
what the enemies were for even fights i
dislike due to their lack of difficulty
like the deacons are still at least
mildly impressive as its leagues better
than the congregation from dark souls 2
which i'm assuming was the inspiration
for it those enemies between the bosses
are allowed to have basic attacks and a
combo or two but the bosses are where
all the creative talent is supposed to
be spilled into it felt like there was
real passion behind these bosses again
from their designs to their movesets and
that's one of the reasons dark souls 3
is held in such a high regard within the
franchise the other reason may also be
down to the locations themselves there
is beauty and destruction as they say
and dark souls 3 proves time and time
again how this is possible the catacombs
the cathedral and the smoldering lake
are all great examples of this but the
way the game shifts this idea and
instead showcases beauty through
architecture again through the lens of
things like irithyll and anor londo is
genius even the smallest things like
looking over a ledge and seeing the rest
of the kingdom or just walking through
the hallway that leads to gwyn's tomb
are beautiful not only because we get to
see some of these locations in a new
more updated light but because from
software has always expertly crafted its
levels to showcase these moments for us
that's one of the reasons anor londo was
so beloved amongst the community is not
only was it the first area that showed
actual signs of life in the world of
lord jam but its design was a sight to
behold even anor londo in its current
state still holds that beauty it's just
a different kind of beauty not how
various pieces of architecture can
create a god-like city that people can
only dream of but how despite its
destruction and loss of life anorlando
still manages to be a beacon of light
and upholds the massive significance
that it displayed in dark souls 1. after
the defeat of aldrich if we retrace our
steps back to irithyll we can find a
separate path that leads to the profaned
capital ruled by yorn the giant
interestingly though we don't just
arrive in the capital as upon exiting
through this hole in the wall we arrive
in the irithyll dungeon this place is a
massive and convoluted prison filled
with all manner of beings who've been
imprisoned and tortured and abused by
all the jailers these jailers are said
to hail from the profane capital but
later served under the rule of pontiff's
sullivan they're also very ruthless in
their methods when it comes to subduing
skbs as they have a poisonous mist that
saps your health away and use a
scoldering piece of hot iron that not
only burns at the touch but will hinder
your ability to run away as you
temporarily fat roll when afflicted if
you manage to escape the prison you'll
be greeted by the underground city of
the profaned capital from a pure
spectacle or design perspective i think
shulva had a much better greeting upon
its entry but the profane capital is
still nice to look at it is admittedly
quite small this could once again be due
to the geological shift of the lands
towards lothric but that doesn't ignore
the fact that the devs could have done a
bit more with its design you'll likely
spend more time in the adjacent dungeon
than in the actual capital while the
area does lack in length it does try to
circumvent the issue a bit by adding a
bit more depth the capital is covered in
various trinkets goblets and burned
corpses and these bodies don't just stop
at the entrance they are in every
section of the capital it's trying to
get the player to wonder what exactly
happened here well the capital was under
attack by a new flame called the
profaned flame this was a curse created
by a group of women and while they did
become disfigured and turn into these
creatures we see just outside the
capital they did manage to win in the
end as it pretty much killed every
single person who resided in said
capital but this is where gorm came in
as he attempted to stop this profane
flame before it caused any damage by
linking the flame and becoming a lord of
cinder but it didn't work as the
aforementioned destruction followed
shortly after the main question
surrounding it though is why do these
women create such a thing and how well
it's possible that it may have ties to
the abyss as both carla the witch and
the profaned cole who are both found in
the irithyll dungeon have ties to the
abyss
you're here to save me
but i'm guilty
a wretched child of the abyss
no words
where did you happen upon this cold
this is much too dark
i see the abyss in it
furthermore we need to look at the
pontiff and elianora pontiff carries a
sword called the profaned greatsword
which states that sullivan discovered an
unfading flame below the tundra of
irithyll in the axe elianora can be
dropped from these monstrous creatures
which says that the women who triggered
the curse were relatives of a certain
oracle these words tundra irithyll of
land covered in snow and oracle all
point to elaine leuce and alsana being
this oracle from what we just talked
about regarding the smoldering lake and
what we know from the old chaos and
elaine loyce it's clear that the flame
of chaos is dying so maybe this is an
altered version of the flame of chaos or
at least maybe the last few sparks of it
it's definitely a stretch but the
profane flame has always been
interesting to me as the last time a new
flame was mentioned in the series
well we kinda know how that went upon
his revival though yorm saw the state of
his city and was in utter shock at what
had occurred so now he sits in despair
unwilling to link the flame but despite
how depressing it would be to kill him
we not only need his ashes but a friend
also needs to uphold his promise
old friend
i
secret of the knights of katarina
have come to uphold my promise
let the sun shine upon this lord of
cinder
when yarn became the ruler of his
kingdom many of the people disapproved
of him in an effort to gain their trust
he created two weapons called the storm
rulers and gave one to his people should
he ever step out of line and the other
to his best friend siegward who promised
to kill him should he come back to life
this is also the final step in secret's
questline and was the main reason i
enjoyed it so much as being able to
fight alongside an npc such as him
against a giant sounds like a blast but
despite the wonderful presentation and
design of yorm's character it's easily
the most underwhelming fight in the game
using the storm ruler is the only way to
do real damage to your the main attack
of the storm ruler is the weapon art
that produces a slash of wind capable of
downing him but that's just it it's just
the same move over and over again doing
this alone is easy and with sigrid it
becomes even easier as you can almost
unlock your arm for a large portion of
the battle and for this to occur during
a fight with a lord of cinder is pretty
pathetic on top of this yarm's second
phase doesn't really change anything it
just adds a bit of fire to his weapon i
feel like there was much more potential
for yorm but it was never given to us
thankfully this wouldn't be the last
time this idea would exist in a souls
game as elden ring repurposed this idea
and it was much better handled there our
final lord of cinder is prince lothric
the one who started this problem in the
first place but the real question is why
it's the one thing that's been rattling
in my head since the very beginning why
did lothric refuse to link the flame
well the answer is honestly a bit sad
prince lothric was born to die the
rulers of lothric were king osiris and
his queen osiris had three children
named lorian lothrick and ocelot lorian
was the first and was a formidable
soldier on the battlefield who was able
to single-handedly defeat the demon
prince who was said to rule over all the
demons osiris figured that his lineage
could push their power even further by
creating a child specifically to become
a lord of cinder and lothric was to be
that child but
he failed lothric wasn't strong enough
so the family committed a deed so
heinous that it cursed him for life
despite the curse though it worked and
lothrick was capable of relinking the
flame but his frail body combined with
his poor health left him bedridden and
resentful being the helpful brother that
he was lorian wanted to combine his soul
with lothrics but because of lothric's
curse it consumed lorian as well which
left him mute and a [ __ ] due to this
the current state of the world and the
fact that even his teacher was having
doubts about relinking the flame it
ultimately caused lothric to refuse and
honestly it's hard to blame him being
created for the sake of power and not
knowing what your sacrifice will truly
do is a hard burden to put on a child
especially when you consider how much
grooming was presumably done to get
lother ready to link the flame had he
been brought up in a different light
this story could have been changed but
due to the greed of the king it
ultimately started a chain of events
that would bring about the end of the
world at the very least though the twin
princes weren't the only ones that
suffered osiris is more dragon than
human now and has gone insane because of
it similar to how big hat logan became
deranged from the knowledge he read on
seath so too did osiris and depending on
what you believe he may also be
hallucinating during the fight he talks
about his son ocelot and we can infer
that he's carrying him in his hand but
nothing is there this however may not be
as obvious as it seems there's currently
two theories i believe in that argue for
and against ocelot's existence on one
hand ocelot may be a hallucination from
the king either because ocelot died and
he can't accept the loss or that he had
been hallucinating the mere idea that he
had a child in the first place however
on the other hand ocelot may actually
exist but was removed due to some
real-world complications during the
second phase of the boss fight osiris
will scream ocelot's name then slam the
hand that carries him into the ground
presumably killing him we can hear a
baby crying in the background during the
fight implying that he lived but i think
this was a loophole by from software to
get rid of complaints killing kids in
games if i'm not mistaken will get a
game banned just about everywhere and
from software has honored this rule and
rarely ever adds kids their games to
begin with the only ones that come to
mind are kuro and sekiro and father
gascoin's daughter in bloodborne but his
daughter is never seen as we're forced
to talk to her through a wall and while
crow does make an appearance numerous
times he is never shown to be harmed
there are three parts in the game that
kuro is actually cut with something and
each time it happens we never actually
see the real act it is of course implied
that he has suffered a wound but it's
never actually shown from software most
likely wanted to add ocelot and his
death to the game but couldn't do to the
possibility of the game being banned
personally i've always been a fan of the
four party and do believe that the king
is not hallucinating and ocelot was
meant to be in the game because this
also connects to the king's current
mindset as he is going so insane that he
doesn't even realize the harm he's
putting his child in but to make matters
worse while the king was consumed by
seath's writings on immortality and the
twins were currently suffering through
no fault of their own the queen had just
decided to leave she disappeared quietly
into the knights from the kingdom and
was never seen again the queen's
identity though is unknown but it is
heavily theorized to be gwynevere from
dark souls 1 we know that gwenevere
bestowed divine blessings to her people
and was seen as a symbol of bounty and
fertility because of it and the divine
blessing of dark souls 3 says that the
queen of lothric was initially revered
as a goddess of fertility and bounty but
the issue is that we know that she left
anor londo and became the wife of a
flame god flan so how did she go from
him to osiris and why did she leave him
and come back here furthermore if
gwendolyn was actually trying to get the
gods back in anor londo how did the two
never find one another and why didn't
gwenevere come back this could have been
due to the presence of aldrich and the
pontiff within the cathedral but this
also calls into question rosaria as her
soul can create the bountiful sunlight
miracle which is one of the miracles of
gwenevere and given the presentation of
both characters from the room's layout
to their positions on the bed it's clear
that there is a connection between the
two brother rosaria is actually
guinevere or simply someone guinevere
new is never explicitly told to us and
really in the grand scheme of things it
doesn't really matter but it is a very
interesting theory nonetheless it's
clear though to no one's surprise that
the royal family is in disarray and is
currently suffering just like the
kingdom is despite this though the
knights of the kingdom still stay strong
and continue to defend the castle
against the corruption that is the pus
of man but it's starting to fight back
as the pus of man is embedded within
these twin wyverns and many of the
castle soldiers and it seems like the
pilgrims of londor have also started
advancing on the castle as they've
managed to control the armor of the
dragon slayer and use it as a tool of
their destruction after battling through
all of this chaos though we can finally
meet the prince himself the twin princes
actually go against the status quo of
the game not just in their decision to
refuse the throne but also in how
they're presented to the player lothric
in a way is this game's gwynne or
vendrick who's clearly not on the same
level as the other two but it was
lothric's choices that set the game's
plot into motion just like how gwyn and
vendrick's choices set their games
blocked into motion instead of being
presented as a shambling corpse lothric
is the opposite even if he's just some
bedridden child that's cursed with a
lifelong illness the boss fight isn't
this sad encounter that makes you feel
like you're doing them a service by
putting them out of their misery you're
fighting a being who is extremely
powerful and is fully conscious of their
actions as opposed to the hollow
versions of the other two it was a
wonderful twist as i expected to be
greeted by a somber tune all while
seeing the death and decay that has
continued to spread throughout the
kingdom reach the prince's chambers but
i didn't and that surprised me and now
is probably a good time to correct a
previous statement of mine a couple
months ago i made a review on dark souls
3. it was a bit more gameplay-centric
than this video is but in that video i
said despite loving the twin princes
lorian had always pissed me off due to
his awful teleportation ability and i
want to rectify that statement as i
never felt these feelings this time
around in the previous video on dark
souls 2 i talked about how the quality
of these bosses will always be a
subjective opinion as the boss's
enjoyment largely depends on the build
and the skill of the player i naively at
the time did not take this into
consideration and never considered that
i was the problem looking at the
gameplay now is downright embarrassing
and i realized that lorian was never the
issue it was me yes his teleport move
does occasionally break line of sight
which is still annoying but everything
was not as bad as i had made it out to
be i always liked the twin princes as a
boss fighter that opinion has never
changed but i think i can now officially
say that it's not only the best lord of
cinder fight in the game but it's easily
one of the few fights in dark souls 3
that i consider completely perfect the
sheer presence of these two is amazing
the fight is pretty much lorien versus
the player lothric is able to protect
lorien with magic and heal him once he
dies the same way the player can heal
with estes and use their equipment to
aid them lothric is like the support
role in this duo but he's also the main
character that needs to be defeated as
he can obviously revive lorian but his
magic forces the player to not engage
them prolonging the fight even longer
than it already is giving lori enough
time to finish us off and the fact that
the duo manages to be a threat no matter
the distance always adds to the
intensity of the fight i've always been
one to admit when i'm wrong and except
the fact that my opinions are never
meant to be set in stone and can always
be changed and this playthrough
thoroughly changed my mind about this
fight as the twin princes are not only
worthy of the title lord of cinder but
were such an excellent boss to put at
the end of the journey
out of all the souls games i ended up
talking about these bosses the most out
of any in the trilogy and this is due in
parts of the lord of cinders being the
only objective in the game so talking
about them is really all we can discuss
they are the main focus of the game and
thus need to have detail lore to back it
up this was forgivable in the other
games as while those beings did have
some importance in the world they
weren't the main focus but in dark souls
3 they are if it wasn't for the lords of
cinder we wouldn't have a game so they
ended up becoming the main focus of the
story and the devs managed to deliver
aldrich is a testament to that statement
as i may have spent more time on them
than any character in the series with
the exception of the witch of izalith
who coincidentally also had numerous
bosses and characters tied to her plot i
was really impressed by the overall
presentation of this game especially
when it came to our four lords of cinder
even including yorm who had a wonderful
design and presentation despite the
fight being a bit black luster their
lore was rich with details and the item
descriptions were long enough to create
an essay's worth of information but also
left enough info out to keep that soul
spirit of finding the context clues and
filling in the gaps plus the encounters
with said bosses made the time spent
getting to them worth it even yorm as
once again despite being disappointing
there was at least an attempt to create
the spectacle of tackling a monolithic
sized giant but if there was one thing
that bothered me about this game it was
the lack of attention given to dark
souls 2. narratively this actually fits
quite well as drangleic was supposed to
be seen as this unimportant kingdom that
would be easily toppled and replaced
with something else in time only to be
forgotten by the rest of the world but
if the point was to make the kingdom
feel unimportant why are there constant
references to it like creighton
appearing in cirrus's quest lucatiel's
armor and asyluteal sword resurfacing in
the game the dead giant at firelink
shrine and not only a portrait of
nashandra but of a lamb loyce and broom
tower found in irithyll it just feels
confusing it's like the team actively
wants the player to know that despite
not making dark souls 2 they are aware
and care about the game but barely put
in the effort to justify it what is
truly the most upsetting part about this
is that both vendrick and aldia to my
knowledge are never mentioned once
throughout the game there is one magic
spell found in the grand archives that
says the words the first of the scholars
which many people have pointed towards a
link to aldia but he was a scholar of
the first sin not a first scholar plus
the first of the scholars could refer to
the scholars of the grand archives not
aldia it's a shame because they were the
only beings that we know of who sought
to break the curse through
unconventional means and there's zero
remnants of their work the two are never
brought up in the game and the actual
structures of draeng lake or aldia's
keep are never seen in game i understand
that dark souls 2 was not everybody's
cup of tea and maybe the original team
wanted to do away with the beat team's
creation but you can't deny that
vendrick and aldia had the potential to
create a sizeable impact on the story
and for their legacy to be tarnished
like this is a bit disappointing with
all the lords of cinder dead and their
ashes within our inventory we can now
link the first flame but before we do
that there is two dlcs and a couple
other bits of content from the main
areas that i want to address first if we
rewind and go back to osiris and visit
the area behind his boss arena we'll
uncover a place called the untended
graves this place is identical to the
cemetery of ash in the beginning of the
game with the only difference being the
lighting it's one of the most talked
about locations within the community as
this confusion coupled with this feeling
of nervousness settles in as upon entry
you start to recognize all the familiar
landscapes and are just bewildered that
a place like this even exists the boss
is also identical as its champion gundyr
as opposed to utics according to his
boss sold description champion gundyr
came to firelink shrine to relink the
fire but failed and arrived too late he
was then eventually bested by an unknown
warrior and given the series have a use
of that term we can assume that this
warrior was us afterwards he then became
a chief of the coiled sword so similar
to oolacile and the memory of the giants
we can go back in the past kill champion
gundyr who then becomes a sheath for the
coiled sword and hopes another warrior
will come and use it to link the flame
who just happens to be us we then take
the sword from his present body as
udyk's gundyr and use it at the bonfire
if we happen to defeat champion gundyr
though we'll be greeted with an
identical firelink shrine and while the
fire keeper is not here there are an
eyes of a fire keeper located inside the
building if we have the eyes in our
inventory ludleth and the fire keeper
will comment on them loveth refers to
the fire keeper as her implying that he
knows the identity of this person and
the fire keeper will mention how these
eyes reveal frightening images of
betrayal in a world without fire so we
can assume that this was in the past and
since ludwig is familiar with the fire
keeper and is a lord of cinder it's
possible that this was during the time
he linked the fire which would also
connect with the intro of the game that
says that the land of lords are
converging together this line just
happens to be ludleths but what doesn't
make sense is the handmaid's dialogue as
in the dark firelink shrine her attitude
seems to imply that the flame is still
lit as she tells us to hurry along but
how is this possible well sadly i don't
have an answer for that the untended
graves is one of the hardest parts of
this game to wrap your head around which
makes discussing it extremely difficult
one explanation though could be that the
fire keeper's eyes are what's causing
this darkness as the world in
present-day dark souls 3 is getting
close to the age of dark as evidenced by
the giant dark sign eclipse in the sky
but there's still plenty of light left
in this world whereas in the untended
graves there's nothing but if all the
lights extinguish and that implies that
this is an age of dark but loveth linked
the flame and continued the age of fire
so that's why i think it's the eyes of a
firekeeper displaying a vision in the
sense of what the world would come to
should we enact this grand betrayal
which is letting the flame die out
another thing of note though is the
repair spell in dark souls 3 which says
that light is time and the reversal of
its effect is a forbidden art so this
implies that the untended graves could
be like the things betwixt it sort of
stuck in limbo because there's no light
existing and therefore time not existing
regardless despite its very confusing
backstory it's probably my favorite
location to discuss in the game as
there's so many possibilities as what
this place truly means
the final location is near irithyll
dungeon as we can use the dragon pose
from the untended graves to be
transported into arc dragon peak we
already know that immortality via dragon
form is not unheard of as many people
worship the stone dragon in dark souls 1
osiris is assumed to be human before he
became a dragon and we can actually find
some dragon stones which will turn us
into a humanoid dragon similar to the
one sitting next to us so it's pretty
safe to assume that this place was used
to worship the ancient dragons despite
the fact that they're all dead now but
even though they're all dead that
doesn't mean the other flying types
won't exist as we get to challenge a
wyvern shortly after arriving which at
first glance is a pretty cool fight
until you realize that the enemies on
the walkways are actually tougher than
the boss itself i can recognize that the
team was most likely experimenting with
some bold ideas for boss fights and
while it's definitely cool at first it
just feels a bit unnatural if you will
as completely destroying its health bar
in one plunge attack just felt off arc
dragon peak not only has a questionable
first boss but also raises various
questions that admittedly may leave
people confused two characters have
arrived at this location at certain
points in time which are habel and
ornstein we find havel next to a downed
dragon and we find ornstein's armor
towards the end of the level i can
forgive havel for being here since he's
always had a hatred for dragons and
seats in stark souls 1 but that doesn't
explain how he's alive well havel had a
band of knights who followed him and
more than likely wore the same armor as
he did so i don't think this is havel
more just a knight of havel but while
this is explained fairly easily ornstein
is not ornstein has always had a
complicated history within the series as
he was clearly present in dark souls 1
but then shows up again in dark souls 2
as the old dragon slayer and then again
in this game as the dragon slayer armor
and in arc dragon peak where we are now
firstly i've always been a firm believer
in the fact that we kill ornstein in
dark souls 1. the old dragon slayer is
simply someone who is trying to uphold
ornstein's legacy or is somehow
connected to ornstein's soul since we
know from dark souls 2 that the old lord
souls can inhibit other's bodies so it's
possible orenstein's soul inhibited
someone wearing his armor it's also
possible that the soul felt comfortable
with this decision given orenstein's
armor is pretty synonymous with his
legacy as for dark souls 3 we know that
the dragon slayer armor is not ornstein
it is simply just another dragon slayer
as the weapon and armor are completely
different but arc dragon peak is unique
this is not only the same armor that
orenstein wore but its item description
talks about how he left the anor londo
cathedral to come here but when did this
happen he couldn't have came here and
then went back to the cathedral as his
armor is located here and he couldn't
have left after dark souls 1 because he
died so the only real explanation that
makes any plausible sense is that
ornstein dies in dark souls 1. he then
has his soul return like the previous
lord's soul wears but decides to inhabit
someone wearing his armor or maybe even
the armor itself as it's familiar to the
soul we talked about in dark souls 2 how
it seemed like the four great ones were
connected to specific lord souls because
of their feelings and emotions we still
don't know whether or not these lord
souls connected with them because of
these similar emotions or if they gain
these feelings from consuming the souls
but if this is true then it would make
sense that ornstein is continuing to
fight the same and has the same goals
and ambitions across all the games
regardless of how orenstein is alive or
how we even ended up here in the first
place we at least know why he was here
and that was because of the nameless
king the nemesis king has actually been
t since dark souls 1 as he was the
infamous first born son of gwyn that was
referenced in various items in that game
from both 1 and 3 we can piece together
that the nameless king is the firstborn
son of gwyn and was a dragon slayer
during the war with the everlasting
dragons but at some point he would
eventually cast all this away and ally
himself with the dragons and if you want
to talk about presentation when it comes
to boss fights this one needs to be
mentioned not only does the introduction
of the boss feel intense as the nameless
king swoops in on a storm drake but when
we finish the drake off he literally
kills it and takes the power for himself
from just a pure gameplay perspective
he's easily the second best fight in the
game there's a feeling that occurs
across the entire series when everything
comes together you've learned the
moveset understood the timings and
discovered the punishes all that's
required is to put it together and when
that clicks it becomes one of the best
fights in the game his moves are
punishing have delays and are even mixed
together as one combo might have two
swings but the next will be three or
will do away with the third swing and at
a completely different move the fight
requires complete concentration and the
ability to be patient dodging too early
will more often than not lead to your
deaths you have to be on high alert for
the whole fight genuinely a great fight
from top to bottom with it only being
surpassed by one being we have yet to
cover but before we move on to the dlc i
want to look back at the game so far
dark souls 3 set out to create a dying
world that features places that have
been ridden with disease and death
showing to the player that their
inability to let go of what they know
and continue this age of fire will only
make things worse even a basic
understanding of the war will convey
this as you can see just how bad
everything has gotten from the fact that
there's hundreds of dead bodies that are
throughout each level and people are
becoming corrupted and infected with
these diseases and plagues causing them
to either go hollow or turn into a
massive black sludge the demon race a
group of beings thought to be on top are
dying out the gods have all been wiped
out and the lords of cinder beings who
have the ability to rule over anything
they please due to their power refuse to
continue this age of fire aldrich wants
to continue his own age so admittedly
that is a bit more selfish but the other
three have recognized that their
sacrifice did or will amount to nothing
linking the flame never stopped the
abyss and never stopped the profane
flame and it's never going to end the
suffering that's occurred since lordran
so the first flame is supposed to be
this symbol of peace and comfort then
what is actually so good about it all
this has been illustrated to us
throughout the story and is a testament
to how genius the writing of dark souls
3 truly is
but now it's time to move on not just to
a new ages that will come later but to a
new world a painted world even this old
man in front of us is gail and he's how
we start the dlc ashes of ariandel we
talked about this place briefly when we
discussed pontiff's sullivan and said it
was a painted world for those without
purpose upon entering we're greeted by a
deformed being who welcomes us and tells
us to get comfortable on a bed of rot
similar to the real world the painted
worlds have their own cycle and it's
this cycle that is so interesting as in
the main game the age of fire is being
constantly prolonged and it's the age of
dark that will take it over but as we'll
soon see it's the rot that's being
prolonged and the only way to get rid of
it is to burn it the painted world of
ariandel is just a similar version of
the dark souls universe with the same
themes and ideas just twisted around
they're both separate worlds with
separate cycles and each one has a
particular cycle that is going on too
long and it's either the fire that's
causing it or the fire that will get rid
of it this is also the reason gail sends
us to the painted world in the first
place as opposed to the corvian we meet
first who tells us to embrace the rot
gale and even this corvian settler want
us to set it aflame setting the painting
of flame will allow a new painted world
to be created but they can't do that
without fire and the person preventing
this is sister freed she is the reason
the rot is being prolonged and she's
also the other ash that the gale and the
corvian refer to meaning she's unkindled
it's because of her decision to keep the
rock going that has caused much of the
destruction of this place interestingly
though only the korvians seem to care as
we talked about the painted world is for
those without purpose and the corvians
aren't the only ones who reside here as
these soldiers are the members of the
undead legion of feren in the beginning
of the video when we talked about the
abyss watchers i mentioned that when
they linked the flame the rest of the
legion left once that occurred the
others no longer had a purpose and
further lost any chance of having one
once they came to the realization that
their home had turned into a swamp
according to their armor these fair and
followers seem to be specifically tasked
with killing any undead legion who
succumbed to the abyss which makes me
wonder how the abyss watchers cutscene
would have played out had the assassins
not left maybe the abyss watchers would
have finally been able to regain their
strength again now that they didn't have
to kill each other the other group of
people are the millwood knights they
don't have too much lore and anything to
really tie any of the characters or
events to them but at some point in time
they lost their forest that they called
home and then sought refuge in the
painted world these groups seem to just
carry on throughout their day and simply
exist within the painted world but the
corvians are different as you have the
regular looking settlers who want to
burn the rod away but then there's also
the corvian knights who were so
infatuated with sister free that they
have now turned against their brethren
just the basic idea of what the painted
world represents to the people within it
is such an intriguing concept but the
way this loosely connects to the main
game's themes is genius one thing i
always found disappointing though about
ashes of arianda was the length once we
enter the painting we're to meet with
sister fried who welcomes us but just as
quickly dismisses our arrival and tells
us to leave because we no longer belong
here i have no issue with this as it's
not holding the player's hand but
everything just feels like it's going so
fast as right after this we're to find
the painter enter the basement of sister
freeze church activate a lever and then
we're already at the final boss
everything just feels so fast and i was
surprised how quickly the final boss was
introduced to me i've talked about
before how most of the souls games dlcs
are like this and don't take much time
overall this of course though largely
depends on how fast you beat the bosses
as they're usually the main hurdles but
ashes of ariendo felt shorter than
normal there is an optional boss that
could take up more of your time but this
was just so that the player could access
the pvp matches and the lore of the boss
also connects to this as this was the
champion of the undead matches that the
undead used to partake in other than
that it's pretty much just going from
one area to the next and the distance
between them is quite short once we do
finish talking with sister freda though
our path will eventually lead us to the
corvian settlements and its church where
we will meet with sir wilhelm he was the
guard that was outside the church where
sister freed was located but what's more
interesting though about sir wilhelm is
that he not only has a black flame buff
on his weapon but he also wields the
darkhand both of which have ties to the
abyss this relates back to sister frida
as she was one of the three sisters of
the sable church her other sisters were
liliane and yuria which means she has
ties to londor and this is reinforced by
the different dialogue options that we
get from her if we have the dark sigils
and our inventory from yuri's questline
it's not much but she does recognize us
as the lord of hollows given that she is
unkindled it's possible that she tried
to link the flame or usurp it and this
possibly got her exile from the church
without a purpose or home she may have
been drawn to the painted world which is
how she ended up here in the first place
and figured that she could rule over
this land by herself however given that
we have this innate ability to ruin
people's plans we're going to prevent
sister freed from doing so to do this we
need to talk to the painter and unlock
the doors leading to her room for her to
be able to paint though she will need to
see flame and to do this we need to get
to the
source again
this is father ariendo the painter of
the painted world of ariandel who is now
being held captive by sister freda she
managed to convince father ariendel that
the only way to preserve the painted
world was to bury the flame and let the
rock consume the world to stop him from
spreading he uses his flail on himself
causing him to bleed which appeases the
flame it's quite a sad story and it
makes sister frida out to be even worse
of a person than she already was given
that we're going against her wishes
though she fights us and she is very
difficult which is also very
entertaining i love this fight and i
think it's a great way to end the dlc
the fight starts out quite normal until
her blood reaches father ariandel who
freaks out causing the room to be
engulfed in flames and him to break out
of his restraints and attack us fruit is
also back and it turns into a 2v1 it's
very reminiscent of ornstein and smoe as
the duo complements each other quite
well this is also the only fight in the
trilogy to my knowledge where you can
summon an npc in the middle of the fight
as gail can only be summoned for the
second phase it also makes sense to
bring him along since both you and him
have the same objective so there's no
reason for him not to help you after
sister frida has been dealt with though
we can return to these
[Music]
yeah so if it wasn't already bad enough
sister frida has a third phase this
whole encounter is extremely stressful
as you not only have to plan for one but
two extra phases there's been so many
times where i got pummeled during this
fight in the first phase that i just
reset as i knew it wasn't worth starting
the next phase with half the estus she
really forces the player to learn her
moveset thankfully though gail does make
the encounter easier but is still very
difficult even with his assistance with
sister freed and father ariendel dead
for real this time the fire will now be
able to consume the painting without any
delays which means the painter can now
work on the new world she plans to
create a cold dark and very gentle place
as she calls it she's going to need
paint to make that painting and from
what we learned from father eryandel's
soul we know that the paintings are
written in blood so gail's objective
will be to scour the land for some blood
to use his pigment and while he does
that we can go on to the next dlc but
gail's here too he has written messages
for us and points us towards where we're
supposed to go so what blood is he
getting well gail is trying to find the
blood of the dark soul the dark soul
which leads him to the ring city ashes
of ariendo was a short but decent dlc
the bosses were great and the actual
design of ariendo was beautiful from its
frozen tundras to its rotted swamps but
if it felt complete or if the dlc
suddenly ended so soon that's the point
as both of dark souls 3's dlcs are a
connected story the story of gale and
the painter and their quest to create a
new world which leads us to the ring
city the start of the ring city dlc sees
us travel to the drag heap the area we
talked about earlier in the video as i
said then time is getting worse as the
world progresses and this is a perfect
example as now that the age of fire is
getting even closer to the end lands are
converging on each other more and more
and the world is practically collapsing
in on itself here in the drag keep we
can see nostalgic callbacks to the past
like the earthen peak windmill and the
desert pyromancer from dark souls 2.
this is a very long and convoluted level
to really showcase how bad everything
has gotten but at the very end of the
level is the demon duo not only is the
gameplay of this fight fantastic as it
not only surpasses the previous duo but
might even be on par as orenstein and
smo but the location of the fight is
heavily theorized to be the original
firelink shrine of dark souls 1. the
reason being is that the exit of this
arena is the same structure that frampt
appears in gail can once again join you
for this fight but it will trivialize
this encounter tremendously as the
demons have long cooldowns between their
attacks and also alternate move sets i
actually found this fight to be balanced
while being outnumbered so adding more
people makes it worse once the demons
are both dead the last one to die gets
to be reborn as the demon prince just
like the first flame the chaos flame
needed to be rekindled by a demon with
vast power and the current demon prince
at the time was going to but ended up
facing lorian and was defeated however
all demons share memories with another
so in theory that means they can share
the power of the demon prince and when
the last demon falls it is reborn as the
demon prince and the last of its kind
the demon prince is a genuinely great
fight and for being the first boss in
the dlc this is already a great start to
the additional content when the demon
prince does fall though we can finally
say goodbye to the demons the once great
race thought to be almost on top has now
withered away never to be remembered
again just like everything else in this
world with the drag keep finished we can
move on to the final location of the dlc
but one thing that's been very
interesting about the drag key was the
progression of time as we go further
down in the game we're actually going
further back in the past as we start out
at the very top in dark souls 3 we move
further down to dark souls 2 with the
earthen peak making an appearance and
then we're all the way at the bottom
where we're back in dark souls 1 with
the firelink shrine but we can go even
further back as past the old firelink
shrine we can travel to the ring city a
place that has existed since the gods
toppled the dragons the ring city is
gorgeous and is one of the most
beautiful locations in the dark souls
trilogy this place is home to the pygmy
lords and they have a wonderful
welcoming committee
oddly enough though these shadow archers
actually look like the ruined sentinels
from dark souls 2. according to their
armor set they were a band of knights
who were sent to the ring city so it's
possible that vendrick may have sent
them here as a way to find out more
about the undead curse but were defeated
and now are used by the city to defend
its people during city is the home of
the pygmies the ancestors of mankind we
don't hear much regarding the actual
furtive pygmy but the ring city is ruled
by the pygmy lords the early descendants
of the original pygmy according to
various item descriptions though gwyn
gave them this city as a reward for
their help against the dragons but since
this is located at the literal edge of
the world it's possible gwen wanted the
pygmies out of sight and away from his
kingdom since they had the dark soul
which of course he does not like as for
how the pygmies helped during the war
what we can find out soon after as these
ringed knights were some of the soldiers
who fought during the war with the
everlasting dragons the weapons they
carry were forged from the abyss since
that was the birthplace of humanity
which would explain the blatant dark
sign on their chest as it seems that
they too were cursed like we were by
gwyn if we progress further into the
level we'll end up in this abyssal swamp
and end up fighting the dragon slayer
armor again and if we read its
description we'll discover that when we
defeated it in lothric it somehow made
its way down here and then became
possessed again by the feeling of battle
look i
love orenstein as much as the next guy
but we do not have to keep bringing him
back we can just let his legacy die i
understand in this case it is just a
piece of armor and not actually ornstein
but you have to admit that this boss's
design is purposely similar to
orenstein's i found this encounter more
annoying rather than interesting as
there was zero reason to bring back the
dragon's lair armor again in the swamp
we can also find a white face locus
similar to the one earlier in the level
these locusts are beings from the abyss
and they were supposed to preach sermons
to men so that they could draw them
towards the dark but they couldn't see
past their stomachs and cared more about
what they were eating which is why they
act like gluttonous monsters this
description means that this is what they
always looked like and didn't turn into
these creatures at some point but it may
also imply that they were born alongside
humanity within the abyss each of them
ends up talking about specific people
and are possibly referencing certain
npcs
and so
she lived in fear
of the dark
of the things that gnawed at her flesh
the little creatures that nibble at me
in the darkness
and so
despite his weighty armor
he lived in fear
of a delicate thing
little more than a girl
where fire resideth shadows twist and
shrivel
but in the
abyss there are shadows none
fear not the dark my friend and let the
feast begin i've always found this
interaction odd as it's unclear how this
creature even knows anything about these
npcs this has caused a bit of debate
amongst many people in the community as
some claim that it's showing how
destructive humanity is but on the other
hand like with the case of iriana's
dialogue the locus preacher could be
implying that the abyss is not as bad as
it seems as that preconceived idea
earing ahead of the abyss caused her to
feel these insect-like creatures in her
head i don't really think that there is
a correct answer here as it sort of ties
into the world of dark souls and how the
player views the abyss humanity and the
age of dark and whether or not it's
something that they should be embracing
similar to how we have to make a choice
at the end of the games before we leave
though we can view this purging monument
which is only accessible to humans as to
even get to this area we need to
transform into a humanity sprite using a
white tree branch this monument may be
the source of all the purging stones
protein stones have existed since dark
souls 1 and were used to remove the
curse effect in that game but it's not
about taking the curse and removing it
it's just transferring it to the stone
itself to be the new host but the stone
is said to once be a person so maybe
these are the beings who were turned
into stone or what they became once we
transfer the curse to the stone or maybe
it's something else entirely after
getting out of the swamp we'll find a
dragon named madir this isn't fake like
the ancient dragon madeir is an actual
descendant of the arc dragons from long
ago even though he only seems to make an
appearance here if we knock him off the
bridge and find a secret tunnel we can
find him again he is easily the most
difficult boss in the entire game with a
staggering 15 000 health and he's also
equipped with some moves that might one
shot the player depending on their
equipment according to his boss soul
madeir was actually raised by the gods
and was tasked with fighting the abyss
and it seems that he's been alive for a
long time as one description says from
not long after the beginning meaning he
may have existed before even fire was
born back when the dragons ruled the
world the reason he's going so crazy is
very similar to artorias as the abyss
has fully corrupted him so we need to
put him out of his misery he is
definitely the ultimate challenge for
players given his kit of high damaging
moves but assuming you can conquer him
you'll receive the spears of the church
which ties into our next boss half-light
half-light is a member of the covenant
spears of the church who guards
philianore who is said to be gwyn's
daughter who he left here in the ring
city but half light is a pvp boss as
there's a chance a real player can
replace half-light and be the boss
instead but that is only accessible to
those who defeat madir since he drops
the pendant that allows you to access
the covenant sadly though since this
game is over six years old you will more
than likely just get half light instead
interestingly though half light may have
been from oolacile as the bow he uses
says that it was a relic from an ancient
land of sorceries that has been
swallowed by the abyss and we know that
oolacile has many unique spells like
repair hidden body and chameleon his
outfit also states that a group of young
missionaries went to the ring city long
ago but half-light stayed behind making
him the final spear of the church this
would also mean that there was a time in
ulysses history and when it wasn't
corrupted by the abyss and was a normal
land before koth came and tricked them
behind the church is filianor the girl
they swore to protect and she may have
one of the best cutscenes this series
has to offer upon touching her egg she
wakes up which sees the world change out
of everything in the dark souls series
this might be at the top as the most
talked about interaction in the game as
there's so much that happens with very
little explanation as to what it means
many people believe that filianore and
her egg held up the illusion of the ring
city similar to gwyndolin and anor londo
and dark souls 1 but some have also
claimed that this takes us to the future
and is a glimpse of what the world will
look like should we keep things going
her egg though is interesting as it has
a very dark center and if we relate this
back to the repair spell from earlier
that's as light as time by breaking the
egg we break the dark inside of it which
allows light to appear meaning now time
exists and is no longer stagnant which
would go along with the theory that this
is a future as the time accelerates
after being stagnant for so long
regardless of what you believe in though
this cutscene is great and allows us to
access the wasteland of ash inside this
wasteland is two beings and if you
subscribe to the theory that this is the
future this might be the last two beings
left in the world us and gail
what still here
handed over that thing
your dark soul
gail has not only gone mad and grown in
size but he is the final boss of the dlc
the ring city was the final dlc and also
the final piece of content in the dark
souls trilogy having played this game on
release i had already beaten the final
boss tons of time so for me gail was
technically my final boss of dark souls
and i couldn't have asked for anything
better to me gale is the best boss in
the game and even the entire trilogy
everything from design to presentation
to gameplay is completely perfect gael
is a slave knight who are knights that
were used as fodder in many of the
land's bleakest wars but it seems most
of them went hollow all except for gale
gill came to the ring city in search of
the dark souls and thus slaughtered the
pygmy lords as they contain the dark
souls within them since they're the
descendants of the furtive pygmy but
gail realized that the dark souls had
dried up so in order to make them liquid
enough to be used as pigment he consumed
the dark souls that they carried since
it was now in his bloodstream it was
able to mix into a liquid again but
doing so made him go mad gail literally
has the power of the dark soul within
his body and uses the power of the dark
soul and the abyss to fight us as
evident by these red skulls that appear
from his cape he and gwyn also contrast
each other in this respect gwyn was a
being who was a god from the beginning
and on top of the food chain and is
remembered by all for his sacrifice but
gail was a slave the lowest of the low
whose sacrifice will be known by only us
a lowly piece of unkindled ash this
sacrifice of gales ties into a theory of
mine after his death we can take the
blood of the dark soul to the painter to
be used as pigment for her new world
gail knew he wouldn't make it back but
continued his mission anyway by handing
it off to us he helps us defeat sister
freda and the demon prince which are the
two required bosses we need to beat to
get to the ring city and once we do get
to the ring city he leaves markings of
his cape along the way that it will
eventually point us towards his location
he wanted us to find him and he wanted
us to defeat him so that we can continue
his mission for him and give the painter
the blood she needed as a whole gale is
easily my favorite character and boss in
this game he is like us a nobody he
isn't some god-like figure or a being
who was born with insurmountable power
he like us gained this power through
battle and now the two strongest beings
in the world are duking it out at the
edge of the world truly the best boss
this game has to offer and was the best
way to end all the dlcs with gail
defeated we can now give the painter the
pigment she thanks us and will
eventually start painting she never
actually finishes the painting though
and this is an important detail just
like the other dlcs in the trilogy this
isn't the end of the game the final boss
is at the kiln it's not gayle so giving
her this pigment doesn't mean the end of
the game it's just one part of our long
journey even if it seems like a
wonderful conclusion to the game the
dlcs of dark souls are the best in the
series and the ring city is a big reason
why ashes of variandel is great and a
nice additional side story especially
since we get to learn more about the
painted worlds but the callbacks
references and answers to questions
we've been wondering about for years are
what makes this dlc so impressive
furthermore both dlcs have some of the
most intense fights in the game and are
the pinnacle of this game's combat from
software has always made their dlcs with
incredible quality and sometimes are
even better than the main game and dark
souls 3 continues to honor this
tradition
gale's objective is now complete so now
it's time to complete ours which is go
to the kiln and determine the fate of
the world once again defending this kiln
is being known as the soul of cinder
this is the physical manifestation of
every being to link the flame since its
inception meaning our characters from
dark souls 1 and 2 are a part of this
being he also fights like a real player
too as his moveset is by far the most
diverse in the game he has three
different melee weapons uses all the
schools of magic and even has the ninja
flip ring from dark souls 1 but our old
characters aren't the only ones in this
being there is one other character we
know of the one who was here from the
very beginning he was the one that
created this world so it's ironic that
he gets to be here for when we destroy
it
[Music]
[Music]
the soul of cinder not only has the same
move set as owen but also the same piano
and it's the music
i'll be honest i get a bit emotional
whenever i hear this
hearing that piano made me think of the
journey i had taken to get here all the
defeats and victories all the npcs i had
encountered all the kingdoms i uncovered
and all the fates of the people i've met
along the way we have seen the literal
rise and fall of the entire world before
our eyes and every single person and
decision we have made has shaped us into
the person we are now a person who now
has to determine the entire fate of the
world should you go against everything
this game has taught you and still
believe in the first flame you'll be
shown a very depressing ending the ashen
1 links the flame and continues the age
of fire but it's not the spectacle we
saw in dark souls 1. it can barely even
cover our character let alone the rest
of the arena the ashen one looks
disappointed as if they expected
something more in fact we the player
were probably expecting something more
and are now just as disappointed this is
why i believe that everyone from gwyn
till now has linked the flame when it
faded as if the world alternated like it
was supposed to then this wouldn't make
sense as to why the flame is this
pitiful the first flame is on its
deathbed and we still haven't granted it
the death it wants if we instead summon
the fire keeper she will take the first
flame and extinguish it for good the age
of dark will commence and the world has
gone completely black and while it may
seem scary to venture into a world
without fire the fire keeper assures us
that the fire will eventually return
someday just like it did all those years
ago remember things are meant to live
and die the age of dark is temporary and
fire will return and an age of fire will
begin again but hopefully it will not be
extended this time if you're feeling
greedy you can also enact the age of
dark and take the flame's power for
yourself this is similar to our final
ending and the secret ending of dark
souls 3 the usurpation of fire this
requires us to complete yuri's questline
yuria is from a place called londor and
we know that she's also the sister of
frida and lillian who created the sable
church in londor but what is londor well
it's a land of hollows as we can see all
the hollows bowing down to us as the new
lord of hollows londor also had many
pilgrims that came to this land possibly
to find the first flame and overtake
lothric those butterflies from the
dragon slayer armor are called pilgrim
butterflies so maybe this is the
pilgrim's final form so to speak these
pilgrims are most likely members of the
sable church as while the sisters
created the church the pilgrims most
likely went here to worship their god
who happens to be the primordial serpent
koth we never see koth in game and the
only reason we even know this is because
of yuri's death dialogue but the call
back to him was insane and almost maybe
nervous for a bit as he could have been
orchestrating this church for who knows
how long so that he finally gets what he
wants if you remember he tricked the
four kings and the people of oolacile
into being engulfed by the abyss so
what's stopping him from doing it
against the people of londor although in
his defense when we placed the lord
vessel in dark souls 1 koth says that
every last one of them failed him so
maybe he isn't trying to screw with
londor and possibly found a genuine
group of people that will follow and
carry out his wish accompanying us into
the new world is also henri of astora
who depending on our actions either got
to defeat aldrich with us and finally be
able to kill the person she hated the
most or gets killed and unwillingly
serves as our bride when we become the
lord of hollows which is quite a dark
twist londor also seems to embrace its
hollow state but this may come at a cost
joel of londor can give us the dark
sigils required to progress the quest
line but once he does that he dies and
the assassin who gives us the wedding
sword dies after the ceremony so it
seems like they're only able to retain
their sanity when hollow but as a
consequence die once their purpose has
been fulfilled this is just about all we
know in regards to londor but there are
still quite a few theories involved with
the kingdom such as the fact that londor
could be tied to drawing lake or velka
admittedly it's a small connection but
items from dark souls 1 and 2 like the
vow of silence dead again dark drift and
dark hand have had their item
descriptions changed the vow of silence
in dark souls 1 is a spell that was
created by velka but in dark souls 3
it's used by members of the church and
the dark drift from dark souls 2 was
said to be used by the grave warden in
the undead crypt but in dark souls 3
it's used by yuria however i don't think
vendrick and aldia are related to this
though as the two of them wanted to
remove the curse and londor wants to
embrace their hollow form although in a
manner of speaking the hollow form is
the true version of man and thus could
be in a way what the brothers desired
but i'm not too sure i believe in this
theory especially given how the brothers
are never mentioned in this game and
would be weird if they finally made an
appearance now regardless now it's time
to say goodbye to the age of fire and to
dark souls the age of dark is a metaphor
for the dark souls series every dark
souls game has taken place in the age of
fire and by keeping this age going we
can keep the dark souls games going but
is that really what we want many games
have gone on to make numerous sequels
and ruin the integrity of that series
the age of dark is not just about moving
on from the age of fire but from dark
souls itself as much as i want more dark
souls games to keep coming it's only
going to ruin the franchise going
forward but that doesn't mean we have to
say goodbye to the souls genre we have
elden ring and any other souls games
that come after it so our hunger for
this genre of games will never die but
we do need to say goodbye to dark souls
having dark souls end now means it ends
on a high note and i'd rather see the
game quit while it's ahead then watch it
release sequel after sequel that will
inevitably tarnish its reputation
causing it to be one of the many games
in the industry that ran itself into the
dirt so it's time to finally put this
game and its world to rest
thank you for watching
[Music]
you